Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch. Das ist einer der saddesten Tage, die ich in einem englischen Fußballplatz gesehen habe. Viele davon sind feindlich. Diese Fans werden sicher sein, dass die 96 nie vergessen werden.
Und sie werden nicht. Mit dem Wert der neuen Beweise in diesem Bericht ist es richtig für mich heute als Prime Minister eine richtige Entschuldigung zu den Familien der 96 für alle, die sie über die letzten 23 Jahre betroffen haben.
Am 15. April 1989 ereignete sich im Hillsborough Stadium in Sheffield beim FA-Cup Halbfinale zwischen dem FC Liverpool und Nottingham Forest ein schweres Zuschauerunglück. 96 Menschen starben, darunter viele Jugendliche. 766 Menschen wurden verletzt. An diesem Montag jährt sich die Tragödie von Hillsborough zum 30. Mal und wir wollen heute in diesem Tribünengespräch zurückblicken auf das, was damals passiert ist und wieso es über 23 Jahre brauchte, bis die wahren Umstände des Unglücks aufgeklärt und in der Öffentlichkeit anerkannt wurden. Am Sonntag, diesen Sonntag, den 14. April, läuft um 23.35 Uhr im NDR die Doku You'll Never Walk Alone zum Thema und ich freue mich, dass ich den Macher der Doku hier begrüßen darf. Ihr kennt ihn sicherlich auch aus dem sehr empfehlenswerten Doppel-Sex-Podcast oder von Twitter. Dort heißt er EdMozOle, aber im echten Leben heißt er Ole Zeisler. Hallo, Ole. Das freut mich sehr, mit dir zu sprechen. Das Thema war schon auf meiner Agenda und dann kamen wir irgendwie über einen glücklichen Zufall zueinander. Ich habe rausbekommen, dass du diese Doku machst und jetzt können wir über dieses Thema sprechen. Sehr schön. Ja, absolut. Und es hat viel mehr Relevanz für den modernen Fußball, als man beim ersten Draufschauen glaubt. Ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum man sich jetzt auch 30 Jahre danach noch befasst. Nicht nur, weil es immer noch aktuell ist. Da laufen immer noch juristische Prozesse ab. Da kommen wir im Laufe der Sendung noch mit dazu. Sondern auch, weil wenn man darüber nachdenkt, dann war das eine Zäsur. Das hat viel mit dem, so wie der moderne Fußball aussieht, auch in den Stadien. Das hat auch mit Hillsborough zu tun. Das macht es irgendwie so aktuell. Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist der Grund, warum auch über all die Jahre viele Medien an dem Thema drangeblieben sind.
Ja, völlig richtig. Ja, genau. Also das hat mich auch tatsächlich in nicht nur der Recherche, sondern auch in diversen Trips dann nach Liverpool oder Sheffield selber auch nicht überrascht, aber schon auch immer ja doch eigentlich doch überrascht, wie präsent das ist in der aktuellen Diskussion den sogenannten modernen Fußball betreffend.
Ja, das wollen wir jetzt alles aufarbeiten und diese Geschichte ein bisschen nacherzählen. Vorher möchte ich noch kurz bedanken bei einigen Rasenfunk-Supportern, nämlich Sebastian, Robert aus Berlin, Klaus Wurz aka Berker, Dirk, Hagi1857 und Mark Fischer. Und ein besonderer Dank geht noch an Henry, der hat bei Instagram gesehen, dass es im Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch zu diesem Thema geben würde und hat mir seine Hausarbeit zum Thema zugeschickt. Tatsächlich ein Dank dafür. Das war mal eine andere Form der Quellenauswertung, die ich da vornehmen konnte vor dieser Sendung. Also da habe ich auch meinen Hut gezogen, muss ich sagen. Das war ein, glaube ich, interessantes Thema. Auch ein guter Prof, wenn man da solche Hausarbeiten abgeben kann und hat mir auch gut gefallen.
Ich habe mit einem Kollegen, der Balesterer, also dem österreichischen Pendant der Freunde, sehr empfehlenswertes Magazin, wie ich finde, gesprochen, der seine Bachelorarbeit über Hillsborough geschrieben hat.
Ach, verrückt.
Siehst du. Ja, es ist auch sehr wissenschaftlich, das Thema.
Ich habe zur Vorbereitung das Buch von Phil Scraton gelesen, Hillsborough – The Truth. Und das ist ja auch ein Professor der Kriminologie, der das Ganze aufgearbeitet hat und zwar seit dem Unglück bis eben dann zum aktuellen Tag. Der hat es aber so wie viele angloamerikanische Wissenschaftler sehr gut geschafft, ein Buch darüber zu schreiben, was sehr wenig an eine wissenschaftliche Abhandlung erinnert und dennoch auf solchen Methoden basiert. Das wollen wir jetzt auch hinbekommen, nur in Podcast-Form, soll kein Wissenschaftspodcast werden. Aber daran werden wir bestimmt nicht scheitern. Danke euch auf jeden Fall für euren Support da draußen. Das ist so eine Folge, wie die hier geben kann, liegt an eurer Unterstützung. Deswegen konnte ich mir die Zeit nehmen, dann hierfür zu recherchieren. Und der nächste Schritt wäre dann, dass ihr hoffentlich uns mal in solche Formen unterstützt, dass dann auch jemand wie Ole noch teilhaben kann. Das wäre dann das nächste Ziel. Ich würde sagen, 2020 spätestens sollten wir das im Rasenfunk erreicht haben. Wie aus Stichwort. Sehr gut, Ole. Jaja, das ist ja sehr nett, aber korrekter wäre es anders. Ich hoffe, wir kommen da im Rasenfunk irgendwann hin. Aber jetzt lass uns ins Thema reingehen. Und man muss bei dieser Hillsborough-Katastrophe, glaube ich, tatsächlich beim Unglück noch mal ein bisschen näher drauf gucken und erklären, was geschah jetzt nicht aus einem voyeuristischen Grund heraus oder um so einen, weiß nicht, Grusel bei den Hörerinnen und Hörern zu erzeugen, sondern weil es eben so schwierig war im Nachhinein zu sehen, was ist da jetzt wirklich passiert, was ist dann vielleicht von den Medien, von den Beteiligten falsch wiedergegeben worden. Deswegen lass uns mal beim Unglück beginnen und dann ein bisschen aufarbeiten, was dann danach alles passiert ist. Also wir sprechen über das FA-Cup-Halbfinale zwischen dem FC Liverpool und Nottingham Forest 1989. Wir müssen aber ins Jahr 1981 zurückgehen, wenn wir so ein bisschen die Geschichte kontextualisieren wollen, denn da gab es schon mal ein FA-Cup-Halbfinale zwischen Tottenham und den Wolverhampton Wanderers. Und auf der Tribüne, auf der es zum Unglück kam, kamen acht Jahre vor diesem Unglück mit den 96 Toten schon 38 Menschen zu Verletzungen. Deswegen gab es lange da keine FA-Cup-Spiele. Erst ein Jahr zuvor gab es am selben Ort dann die gleiche Partie. Und da entging man kurz einer Katastrophe, nur weil Fans aufs Spielfeld kletterten. Da kann man noch bei YouTube Bilder finden, das ist durchaus beeindruckend zu sehen, wie da immer, immer mehr Fans einfach über die Zäune gesprungen sind und dann recht brav am Spielfeldrand saßen. Das ist so ein bisschen der Kontext zu dieser Ansetzung und die FA hat mutmaßlich nach allem, was man heute weiß, unter anderem die Entscheidung wieder zurückzukehren ins Hillsborough-Stadion in Sheffield auch zum Anlass genommen, dass es einen sehr erfahrenen Polizeiinspektor vor Ort gab, der dann für die Sicherheit im Stadion zuständig war. Der wurde nur leider 21 Tage vor dem Spiel ersetzt durch David Duckenfield, der den Polizeiansatz dann vor Ort beim Spiel regeln sollte. Und das war sein erster Einsatz. Sein Vorgänger, David Mole, war nicht mal im Stadion, der war am 15. April woanders im Einsatz. Das ist so ein bisschen der Rahmen, den wir jetzt vielleicht mit einem Bild ausstatten können. Du warst ja vor Ort in Sheffield. Kannst du uns mal beschreiben, was ist denn das für ein Stadion?
Also, ich finde, wenn man nordenglische industrielle Romantik mag, ein schönes Stadion, als dass das ein klassischer Kasten, relativ zentral mitten in einer kleinen, ich möchte fast sagen grauen nordenglischen Stadt ist. Sheffield ist von Liverpool schon so anderthalb, zwei Stunden entfernt. Wir sind darüber gefahren, von Liverpool aus, weil wir dort einen der Überlebenden getroffen haben. Es ist eine wunderschöne Strecke dort durch Yorkshire, weil Yorkshire so, finde ich, die schönste Gegend in England ist, egal zum Wandern und so weiter. Aber das Stadion selber ist etwas modernisiert, aber die Leppings Lane, also das Ende, wo damals die Liverpool-Anhänger reingegangen sind oder sich reingedrückt haben oder reingedrückt wurden, da kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch zu, es einfach geht von so einer Hauptstraße ab und dann gehst du direkt wirklich rein durch einen damaligen Tunnel in das Stadion. Es ist so ein richtig schönes, Stahlträger-Wellblech-artiges Stadion mitten in Sheffield und Sheffield Wednesday, so heißt ja der Club, auch wenn der mit dem Spiel ja nichts zu tun hat, heißen ja auch The Olds, die Eulen, da gucken dich immer so etwas, ich finde es passt so ein bisschen, da gucken dich so, ich finde ja Eulen immer etwas grimmig reinschauen und diese Eulen gucken dich von jeder Stadion-Ecke so ein bisschen an. Aber es ist klassisch Englisch, es ist aus meiner Sicht ein schönes, kaltes, industrielles Stadion, sehr gut.
Jetzt wissen wir im Nachhinein, dass die Einlasssituation mehr als suboptimal war, also es gab insgesamt 23 Drehkreuze für die insgesamt über 25.000 Fans, die auf diesen Teil des Stadions, in diesen Teil des Stadions wollten und an dem Bereich, wo es dann zu der Lappingslane ging, zu den Stehtribünen, wo eben die meisten Zuschauer hin wollten von Liverpool-Fans, nämlich 10.000, gab es nur sieben Drehkreuze, alles sehr eng und schon auf den Lageplänen, die man jetzt im Internet natürlich zuhauf finden kann, sieht man, nach heutigen Maßstäben würde man so ein Stadion nicht mehr installieren. Ist es denn aktuell immer noch so, dass es ein bisschen beklemmend und eng wirkt oder wie hat das auf dich den Eindruck gemacht, jetzt das aktuelle Stadion?
Also beklemmend kann ich natürlich, weil ich da keinen emotionalen Bezug zu habe, kein retrospectiven Bezug zu habe, kann ich nicht wirklich beurteilen. Ich weiß nur, der Überlebende, der damals da war, der mir im Übrigen auch sein Ticket gezeigt hat, das fand ich ganz spannend. Er hat damals sechs Pfund dafür ausgegeben. Sechs Pfund hat das Ticket gekostet. Ich fand es ganz interessant, dass der das Ticket immer noch hat für die Lappings Lane, für PEN3 und PEN4. Beklemmend kann ich nicht so ganz sagen, aber es wirkt schon, natürlich fährt man unter diesem Eindruck dorthin als Journalist oder Filmemacher, wie auch immer, wirkt das schon dicht eng. Also wenn du hier vom Volkspark aus gehst, also ich komme ja aus Hamburg, oder klar St. Pauli ist da auch zu klammern, aber auch Gladbach auch so, die Stadien liegen mittlerweile auch in München leider an Autobahnausfahrten und so, das ist natürlich nicht mehr in England nicht so, also allein dadurch hast du so einen Eindruck, dass das allein deshalb schon eng wirkt, allein durch die lokale Anordnung so eines Stadions. Und ja, auch dann, obwohl der Überlebende, mit dem ich dort da war, er sagte ja, die haben ja einiges geändert, die Turnstiles, also die Drehkreuze, die du ansprichst, die gibt es in der Form nicht mehr, die haben sie auch entfernt abgebaut, wirkt es trotzdem eng und ich glaube auch trotzdem freimachend unter dem Ganzen, wenn man weiß, was dort passiert ist.
Wie war das, mit einem der Überlebenden da vor Ort zu sein? Das stelle ich mir also für ihn vor allem hart vor.
Ja, war es auch de facto, also das, genau, man könnte jetzt blöd Thomas Gottschalk mäßig sagen, ja, dann gucken sie mal meinen Film an, aber darum geht es natürlich auch, dass es für ihn schon auch eine Art Überwindung war, ich habe ihn natürlich möglichst in meiner bekannten sensiblen Art gefragt, ob er sich das zutrauen kann, nein, Spaß beiseite.
Also war er zum ersten Mal wieder da?
Nein, es gab mal irgendwann, ich meine vor zehn Jahren gab es eine Art Gedenkfeier, ich glaube diese Paarung gab es in Hillsborough nie wieder, also Liverpool gegen Nottingham ohnehin nicht, aber diese beiden Vereine haben sich in dem Stadion nie wieder getroffen, also Liverpool und Sheffield, will ich damit sagen. Meine ich, er hat mir das gesagt, na da wird gegoogelt jetzt bestimmt, aber egal, aber für ihn war das komisch, aber er wollte das und das ist so der Punkt, den ich ganz interessant finde, weil er jemand ist oder auch diverse Überlebende, oder ich habe fünf Überlebende insgesamt getroffen, die so ja quasi meine Protagonisten auch sind in dem Film, die tolle Menschen, tolle Männer finde ich, die wollen die Geschichte weiter erzählen, die wollen das erzählen, den behagt das nicht, an solchen Orten zu sein, den behagt das auch hier und da nicht darüber zu sprechen, aber sie sagen klar, sie möchten das weiter erzählen, weil sie sind diejenigen, im Gegensatz zu natürlich, so zynisch das klingt, Opfern, die es nicht überlebt haben, aber auch Angehörigen, die nicht da waren, finden sie es wichtig, zu erzählen, wie es war. Ich finde das ganz interessant, Überlebende zu befragen oder dementsprechend Augenzeugen, im Gegensatz zu, also Opfer kann man nicht mehr fragen, so blöd das jetzt klingt, das ist eh klar, aber auch Angehörige, weil die, die waren da, die können es erzählen. Und deshalb war es, wie gesagt, um zu deiner Frage zurückzukommen, beklemmend mit diesen Menschen dort zu sein. Für ihn war das auch eine gewisse Überwindung, aber er wollte das, er wollte das nahezu aktiv, ja, ja, ich möchte dahinten und ich möchte mit dir darüber sprechen. Deshalb habe ich da einerseits total den Hut vorgezogen, habe der wahnsinnigen Respekt vor, aber er wollte es auch.
Okay, also wir zeichnen ein bisschen das Bild. Wir haben eben das Hillsborough Stadium in Sheffield, mitten in der Stadt, so wie du es beschrieben hast. Wir hatten damals, im Jahr 1989, eben 23 Drehkreuze, erstmal für die kompletten 25.000 und dann eben aber sieben Drehkreuze für insgesamt 10.000 Zuschauer für diese Stehtribüne, was übrigens schon 1986 von einem Polizeiinspektor angemahnt wurde. Also im Nachhinein gab es sowieso ganz, ganz viele Punkte, an denen man sagen muss, hättet ihr euch einfach nur an Empfehlungen gehalten oder sogar einfach nur an die Regeln, dann hättet ihr euer Stadion anders gestalten müssen. Das war allerdings damals auch eine Kostenfrage und Usus in den englischen Stadien. Also wenn man sich mal in die Historie der Stadionunglücke ein bisschen einliest, dann sieht man verschiedene Vorkommnisse, wo man gedacht hätte, okay, jetzt müssen eigentlich auch die Clubs, der Verband, die Behörden vor Ort müssen aufwachen und da etwas tun. Also es gab in Burnton Park 1946 schon ein Spiel mit 33 Toten und über 500 Verletzten, auch ein FA-Cup-Spiel. Und auch da war es so, so wie wir jetzt gleich schildern werden, dass sich ein Ausgangstor geöffnet hat und durch das sind dann ganz, ganz viele Zuschauer ins Stadion gekommen. Und so wurden dann am vorderen Ende, ohne dass das diejenigen, die hinten gemerkt hätten, die hinten reingekommen sind, sind am vorderen Ende Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Und gerade 1985 ist noch, also ich will jetzt hier nicht die komplette Historie zurück erzählen, aber 1985 ist in Bradford City eine komplette Holztribüne abgebrannt, ausgelöst von einer Zigarette. Es gibt, erstaunlicherweise ist das Video der Live-Übertragung damals, was ja auch nicht üblich war, dass alles live übertragen wird, in kompletter Länge noch auf YouTube zu sehen. Ich kann es euch ehrlich gesagt nicht empfehlen, weil man sieht zwar sehr… Ja, und zwar auch wieder, wie der Kommentator das live kommentiert hat. Also ich habe da nur in Ausschnitten reingeguckt, weil das ist nicht so mein Ding, so Dinge mir anzugucken, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, okay, ich muss mir kurz, wenn wir jetzt dieses Thema haben, muss ich da mal reingucken. Also man sieht, das war eine komplette Holztribüne, unter der der Müll aus 30 Jahren Fußballstadion Geschichte lag und dann hat eine Zigarette, die in Flammen aufgehen lassen. Und auch da war aber das wesentliche Problem neben dem, wie schnell das Feuer um sich gegriffen hat, dass die Leute nicht sicher von diesen Tribünen runter kamen. Und das ist in Hillsborough das wesentliche Thema gewesen, weil Fans damals nicht unter dem Aspekt der Sicherheit gesehen wurden, sondern unter dem Aspekt der Gewalttätigkeit. Also wenn du sagst, es gibt die Pens 3 und 4, das sind die überfüllten Blöcke, in denen das Unglück passiert ist in Hillsborough, dann ist Pen mit Block eigentlich ein bisschen falsch übersetzt. Ich weiß nicht, man müsste es vielleicht eher Käfig nennen oder Gatter, weil es gab eben einfach nach vorne einen Zaun ohne Unterbrechung und zu den Seiten vor allem auch Zäune. Das heißt, das waren quasi Fans in Käfighaltung, würde ich es fast formulieren.
Ja, absolut. Vielleicht ist das wirklich die bessere, zweifach stastischere Übersetzung, aber das stimmt schon. Das ist so ein bisschen mit den, ich sag mal, letzten Auswärtsblöcken auch hier in Deutschland oder immer noch fortwährenden Auswärtsblöcken hier in Deutschland auch zu vergleichen. Wie du sagst, rechts und links geht nichts, nach vorne geht nichts und hinten kannst du oder über oben kannst du reingehen und dann bist du da drin wie ein Tier, um in der Konnotation des Käfigs zu bleiben.
Also wirklich im Nachhinein, natürlich weiß man jetzt auch besser, aber man kann da nur den Kopf schütteln. Es gab nach vorne zwei Sicherheitstore, die wurden aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr spät erst aufgemacht. Zu den Seiten gab es jeweils eine Tür, die war verschlossen, die Tore vorne waren aber auch nur, ich glaube, 100 Zentimeter breit. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir darüber sprechen, dass dann der Platz da geflutet wird, wenn du die aufmachst. Also mit heutigen Maßstäben nicht mehr zu vergleichen und dass sich das geändert hat und auch einiges anderes. Das hängt eben auch mit Hillsborough zusammen. Und wichtig ist eben der Aspekt, wenn man sich mit diesem Unglück befasst, dass eben Fußballfans damals unter dem Aspekt der Gewalt gesehen wurden. Gewalt, Alkoholismus, Hooliganismus, das waren die Schematar, mit denen die polizeilichen Behörden und auch die Vereine Fans gesehen haben. Das heißt, Fans waren nicht etwas Gutes, sondern man musste sich vor ihnen schützen. Man musste sie gegenseitig voreinander schützen. Und es ist ja auch mit der Heisel-Katastrophe, die vier Jahre vor Hillsborough stattfand, beim Finale im Europapokal. Der Pokalsieger war es, glaube ich, also Liverpool gegen Juventus Thüringen in jedem Fall in Brüssel. Da hat sich das ja auch bestätigt. Da kam es zu insgesamt 39 Toten und über 450 Verletzten, weil Liverpooler Hooligans in einen eigentlich neutralen Block, in dem aber vor allem Juventus Thüringen-Fans standen, eingedrungen sind und dann eine Massenpanik ausbrach und eine Wand, eine Mauer zum Einsturz kam. Also da kam dann marode Stadionsituation und aber in dem Fall tatsächlich Gewalt von Fans zum Tragen.
Genau, das darf man tatsächlich, ich hätte es gesagt, wenn du es nicht gesagt hast, es war immer noch ein Eindruck von Heysel, 89 oder auch in den Jahren nach Heysel, 85 war Heysel, unter diesem Eindruck waren noch so eine allgemeine Gemäge, die englischen Vereine waren gesperrt oder Liverpool war gesperrt, alle Englische waren in Liverpool, nur Liverpool, weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht, für einen europäischen Wettbewerb.
Es waren alle für fünf Jahre gesperrt und Liverpool sechs Jahre.
Und unter diesem Eindruck war das Ganze noch und es ist nicht so, ich habe mir so Bilder auch, nicht nur YouTube, auch bei uns im Archiv von 87, 88 anguckt. Also jetzt mal überspitzt gesagt, gab es bei jedem dritten Spiel einen Platzsturm auch. Also es war nicht so, dass da nur Waisenknamen unterwegs waren. Das muss man leider, ich vergesse die Wertung, aber das muss man schon auch anmerken. Also das war einfach eine andere Zeit. Unter diesem Eindruck passierte Hillsborough zu einem, ganz blöd gesagt, sehr falschen Zeitpunkt.
Genau, aber ein Stück weit musste das vielleicht auch passieren. Wenn man sich mit diesen Bedingungen auseinandersetzt, mit der Art und Weise, wie damals Stadion gestaltet waren, wie Fußballfans behandelt wurden, wie sie sich zum Teil aber auch verhalten haben, war das vielleicht zwangsläufig, dass das irgendwann mal passieren musste. Und nur Ort und Art waren vermutlich dann die Variablen in dieser Geschichte. Das ist eine etwas bittere Wahrheit und hört sich vielleicht auch zynisch an. Aber den Eindruck hatte ich jetzt bei der Recherche. Damals waren einfach Stadien und alles, das war noch nicht auf Massen ausgelegt. Und da gab es Sicherheitskonzepte, da würde man heutzutage, würde da ein Achtjähriger schon sagen, Moment mal, also so kann das ja nicht funktionieren. Und unter anderem ja auch sieben Drehkreuze für 10.000 Menschen. Das ist das Halbfinale im Pokalwettbewerb. Im Finale wartet vermutlich der Erzrivale Everton, also Liverpool und Everton damals auch sportlich, das Beste, was der englische Fußball zu bieten hatte. Da kannst du dann auch mit einem großen Andrang rechnen. Samstagnachmittag war dieses Spiel. Also da kamen einfach viele Dinge zusammen und gipfelten dann in unglücklichseliger Weise in dieser Tragödie.
Genau, aber das, was du sagst, man kann so sagen, es musste irgendwann passieren, was die Stadionplanung oder auch die Sicherheitsplanung anging. Es war nur die Interpretation dessen, war dann irgendwie so interessant, da kommen wir sicherlich noch gleich zu, das meine ich mit Hillsborough, ist eigentlich zur falschen Zeit passiert. Und ich nenne immer gewisse Menschen, gewisse Interpretation, gewisse Ereignisse, ja Überschriftenleser. Also es gibt so Strömungen oder auch Interpretation von Ereignissen, wo viele sagen, ja das war ja klar, dass das eben dann passiert, war doch logisch. Und genau da in dieser Phase passierte Hillsborough, weil viele sagten, okay, Hooliganismus, wir hatten Heisel, Liverpool sowieso, Liverpool-Fans waren in Heisel proaktiv tätig, sei jetzt mal so. Und genau das ist das Problem, genauso wie du es schilderst. Es musste irgendwann passieren, haben ganz viele Menschen dann gesagt, dabei stimmt es ja nicht so ganz, weil, naja, wie wir wahrscheinlich gleich noch erörtern, die Umkehr der Schuld sehr spät kam oder nicht die Umkehr der Schuld, mindestens mal die Entlastung der Fans kam ja sehr spät. Und das ist so, finde ich, so spannend in dieser Geschichte. Das ist so ein Knackpunkt, dass so ein Katalysator für viele Vorurteile oder Empfindungen oder auch bereits oder Headlines gewisser, vielleicht auch reißerischer Medien waren, dass das passiert. Und dann wurde daraus sehr viel gemacht. Und das ist so spannend, leider negativ spannend an dieser Geschichte, finde ich.
Ja, das stimmt. Und da kommen nämlich auch viele Dinge, also wir werden ja dann auch nur über die mediale Aufbereitung von Hillsborough sprechen, aber da kommen eben viele Dinge aus der Zeit mit hinein, wo man auch das größere Bild aufmachen muss und sich eben England in diesen 80er Jahren angucken muss. Liverpool als eine Stadt, die unter dem Sparkus von Margaret Thatcher besonders leidet, die sich dagegen aber auch auflehnt. Die hatten zwischendurch mal eine linke Regierung, also in Liverpool selbst, die dann aber unter, ich würde sagen, merkwürdigen Umständen dann von London aus wieder, ja, ersetzt wurde durch etwas weniger kritische Politikerinnen und Politiker, ja, damals noch vor allem Politiker tatsächlich. Und eben dieses ganze Umfeld, in dem sich England damals befand, eben auch mit Thatcher, der eisernen Lady, die mit ihrem Sparprogramm auch, ja, den Briten nicht die beste Zeit ihres Lebens beschert hat und gleichzeitig suchte man natürlich aber auch nach anderen Sündenböcken und konnte dafür auch viele Themen auch im Fußball finden, wo es sehr einfach war zu sagen, da verhalten sich Fans wie Tiere, da werden Regeln gebrochen, Autoritäten werden nicht wertgeschätzt, da ist, also in dem Fußball in den 80ern hat sich da auch so wie so ein, weiß nicht, Schmelztiegel kamen da viele Dinge zusammen und das sieht man irgendwie auch am Umgang mit Hillsborough.
Also ich kann mich nur wieder auf meine Treffen mit diversen hauptsächlich Überlebenden beziehen. Wenn du die auf Thatcher ansprichst, egal ob vor oder nach Hillsborough, speziell nach natürlich, wenn du da nur den Namen Thatcher sagst. Jedes Mal.
Alle. Ja, es ist ja auch nachvollziehbar. Lass mal noch kurz erklären, was jetzt dann eigentlich passiert ist. Also wir haben dieses Spiel. Um 15 Uhr soll es angepfiffen werden. Zwischen 14.30 und 14.40 staut sich's an diesen besagten Drehkreuzen so sehr, dass auch die Polizisten vor Ort sich nicht mehr frei bewegen können. Polizei, Pferde schaffen's irgendwie gerade noch aus diesem Gedränge raus, aber können nicht mehr für Ordnung sorgen. Es wird die Bitte an die FA herangetragen, den Anpfiff um 20 Minuten zu verschieben, weil die Leute natürlich langsam so ein bisschen Angst haben, die ersten Minuten zu verpassen. Diese Bitte wurde aber abgelehnt. Das wurde interessanterweise gar nicht so sehr später aufgearbeitet.
Dass das nicht so schwerwiegend war, genau. Dass dieser Bitte nicht nachgekommen wurde.
Also wo wäre das Problem gewesen? Wir sprechen ja damals noch nicht. Also das irische Fernsehen hat live berichtet, aber ansonsten lief dieses Spiel in Ausschnitten. In Grandstand hieß, glaube ich, damals die Sendung im britischen Fernsehen. Also da hat auch die FA sich merkwürdig verhalten. Aber wie dem auch sei, es wurde immer voller da. Allein wenn man die Bilder sieht, wird es einem schon beklemmt und da sind wir jetzt noch nicht mal im Stadion. Und dann passiert das Entscheidende nämlich um 8 vor 3, also 14.52 Uhr, öffnet die Polizei auf dringendes Bitten eines Polizeioffiziers, der dort in der Menschenmasse stand, ein Tor, das eigentlich nur als Ausgang gedacht war und darüber kommen dann, man ist sich nicht sicher, wie viele Fans – ich habe was gelesen von 2000, was gelesen von 1000 – aber eine Menge an Fans strömt ins Stadion und dann passiert das Fatale. Das an sich allein wäre noch, wenn wir mal davon absehen, dass diese Fans nicht kontrolliert wurden, wäre das nicht schlimm gewesen, aber das wirklich Fatale ist, die alle strömen zu diesem Tunnel, der scheinbar der einzige Zugang zur Stehtribüne zu sein scheint, weil er schlecht ausgeschildert ist. Es hätte auch noch andere Wege gegeben in die anderen Käfige, in die anderen Pents und so drängen jetzt eben diese Fans in den Tunnel hinein und vorne in den in den Blöcken direkt hinter dem Tor können die Massen diesem Druck nicht mehr standhalten. Und jetzt kommt es eben zu dieser Situation, dass die eh schon vollen Blöcke völlig überfüllt werden und diejenigen, die hinten reinkommen in den Tunnel, die sich einen Weg nach vorne bahnen wollen, gar nicht mitbekommen können, was vorne direkt an den Gittern zum Spielfeld passiert.
Dieser Tunnel ist quasi diese Trichterform für viel zu wenig Menschen, die sich dann wieder versuchen, auszutrichtern in diese Käfig oder Pens 3 & 4. So verstehe ich das auch oder so wurde es mir auch erzählt. Und dieser Tunnel ist vier Meter breit, irgendwie sowas. Und der ist auch nicht besonders hoch. Ich habe Bilder von dem Tunnel, den gibt es nicht mehr, diesen Tunnel, gesehen. Und da muss es wirklich… Die Leute müssen sich gestapelt haben, also bis zur Decke gedrückt haben. Dieser Tunnel ist vielleicht zwei Meter 20, zwei Meter 40 hoch. Und der war wirklich… Ja, also schlichtweg, das kann ja nur zu einer Art Massenpanik, oder nicht zu einer Art, sondern zu einer Massenpanik führen. Und diese Trichterform dieses Tunnels war die absolute Katastrophe. Und wie du richtig sagst, das Problem war eben, dass dieses zusätzliche Tor, was eigentlich ein Fluchttor war, geöffnet wurde. Genau. Also, es war fast physikalisch, oder ja, physikalisch eigentlich. Ich weiß nicht. Ich bin Naturwissenschaft nicht so gut. Aber du weißt, was ich meine. Es kann gar nicht funktionieren, will ich eigentlich nur sagen.
Genau. Der Tunnel fiel um sechs Prozent Neigung, waren es, glaube ich, ab. Das heißt, du wurdest auch quasi nach unten geleitet. Und das hat dann dazu geführt, es hat später eine der Überlebenden beschrieben, die schon im Tunnel war, als dann die Menschen durch das Tor noch mit dazu kamen. Das hätte sich angefühlt, als wäre ein Zug von hinten in dich reingefahren. Also du konntest auch gar nicht mehr dich bewegen. Die Menschen standen so eng beieinander, dass sie ihre Hände da hatten, wo sie sie hatten, oben, unten. Du konntest nichts mehr tun. Es gab dann Fans, die kamen dann zwar aus dem Tunnel raus, wurden währenddessen aber gedreht und die hatten keine Möglichkeit, mehr sich umzudrehen. Also die haben dann nicht das Spielfeld gesehen, sondern nur noch nach hinten in den Tunnel. Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen. Man findet dazu auch ganz viele Schilderungen, die habe ich uns allen im Intro erspart, weil ich fand, das musste eigentlich nicht sein, um diesen Schrecken darzustellen. Also man kann es sich kaum vorstellen. Das Entscheidende ist aber, Dackenfield, der Polizist, der eben dafür zuständig war, den Einsatz vor Ort zu leiten, der hat die Order bestätigt, dieses Tor aufzumachen und hat aber nicht gleichzeitig dafür gesorgt, dass dieser Tunnel zugemacht wurde, so wie es übrigens früher schon war. Also es gab ein Spiel gegen Manchester United, da ist genau das passiert. Und es gab wohl angeblich auch ein Schiebetor, was man zumachen konnte, oder mit Polizisten vor Ort. Er hat irgendwann mal gesagt, er hätte gedacht, die Stadionbetreiber wären für das Crowdmanagement zuständig. Aber da sind wir dann schon in einem Bereich, in dem so viele komische Aussagen getätigt wurden, dass man dann sowieso eigentlich nichts mehr für bare Münze nehmen konnte. Aber das war das Fatale. Und ohne jetzt weiter ins Detail zu gehen, wie es in den Pens aussah, wenn es euch wirklich interessiert, dann findet ihr auch fürchterliche Fotos dazu in allen möglichen Dokumentationen und Filmen. Ich kann es mir ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr angucken. Das Spiel ging los. Um 5 nach 3 schießt noch Peter Beazley von Liverpool an die Latte von Nottingham. Das hat wohl tatsächlich dazu gesorgt, dass nochmal ruckartig sich die Menschen nach vorne bewegt haben. Das war noch ein wesentlicher Faktor, der ganz vorne an den Zäunen dazu geführt hat, dass jetzt schon die ersten ihr Leben lassen mussten. Fans versuchen auf dem Block zu klettern.
Entschuldigung. Genau, weil du Peter Beazley ansprichst. Ich finde das, das habe ich vorher auch gelesen, wie gesagt, fünfte Minute, das ist eine Ecke von Liverpool. Das Spiel lief ja schlichtweg und die Leute, wahrscheinlich starben sie bereits. Das war aber auf der anderen Seite. Liverpool war dementsprechend im Angriff, also auf der Leite der Nottingham Forest Fans. Peter Beazley hat nach einer Ecke übrigens ein wunderschöner Schuss, ich habe mir das Spiel, also dieses 6-Minuten-Spiel, habe ich mir angeschaut, ein wunderschöner Volley-Schuss. Peter Beazley hit the crossbar, ist so ein geflügeltes Wort in England, also trifft die Latte. Und wie du richtig sagst, danach, das hat mir einer der Überlebenden auch beschildert, wie es üblich ist, so eine Masse reagiert, trotz aller Not, trotz aller Missstände, immer noch auch irgendwie aufs Spiel und alle Köpfe recken sich nach diesem Spiel, immer eine FA-Cup-Halbfinale und so weiter. Und das, wie soll ich das sagen, das finde ich eine irre Geschichte, dass das sportliche dann auch nochmal bestimmt, also das wäre auch ohne diesen Latten Schuss leider Gottes alles passiert. Aber das finde ich so eine irre, zynische, tragikomik dieser Geschichte, dass wenn einer an die Latte schießt, dass dadurch ein Wellenbrecher bricht, der ist wirklich gebrochen, wie ich gerade sagte, und dadurch noch mehr Panik, noch mehr Enge, noch mehr Verletzungen oder auch Opfer entstehen. Vielleicht nicht noch mehr als am Ende, aber so, in der 6. Minute wurde es ja dann abgebrochen. Aber das finde ich irre. Es ist wie gesagt, es ist irgendein Sprichwort, ich habe es bis heute nicht ganz verstanden, in Liverpool oder in Nordengland, Peter Beardsley hit the cross bike, ich versuche das immer noch zu ergründen, für was das so steht. Das ist irgendwie eine Metaphorik auf irgendeine alltägliche Situation. Wenn irgendwas noch schlimmer wird, so habe ich das verstanden, weißt du?
Vom Regen in die Traufe vielleicht so ein bisschen. Genau. Ja, also völlig irre. Im Nachhinein auch wirklich irre, dass dieses Spiel angepfiffen wurde. Denn es ist surreal. Du hast ja ein Dreiviertel Stadion, das normale Fußballstimmung produziert. Und scheinbar ist es auch auf der Liverpooler Seite so, wenn du dir aber das Publikum anguckst. Und das haben eben dann im Nachhinein auch ganz viele Leute, die an anderen Orten im Stadion waren, gesagt. Dann hast du gesehen, die haben sich nicht mehr bewegt. Also die waren quasi so aufeinander gestapelt, dass du schon gesehen hast, irgendwas stimmt da nicht. Das ist nicht korrekt. Das ist dann auch wesentlich dafür gewesen bei der Bewertung der Frage, hätte die Polizei das nicht erkennen müssen, die mit Kameras auf diese Blöcke gefilmt hat, wo der Zoom funktioniert hat und alles so ausgerichtet war, dass die das eigentlich hätten sehen müssen. Und man weiß jetzt im Nachhinein, die ersten Menschen sind um 15 Uhr schon gestorben, mit dem Anpfiff. Um 15.05 Uhr brach dann dieser Wellenbrecher. Das hat dazu geführt, dass ganz viele Menschen übereinander gefallen sind. Ein Berg aus Fleisch habe ich irgendwo gelesen. Es ist eine fürchterliche Metapher, die aber leider auch beschreibt, was da passiert ist. Und ab diesem Moment, das wurde auch später, diese 15.05, 15.06 Uhr Zeit, die wurde dann nochmal sehr wichtig. Ab diesem Moment gibt es für manche Fans vor allem unten an den Gitter keine Rettung mehr. Und auch jugendliche Fans sind da, deswegen sind auch so viele Jugendliche unter den Opfern, nicht nur wegen der Zusammensetzung des Blogs, sondern man kann sich ja vorstellen, wem zuerst im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes die Luft ausgeht in einer solchen Situation.
Und entschuldige, wenn ich einhacke, Jugendliche ja. Ich musste daran denken, weil das jüngste Opfer war ja zehn Jahre alt, wenn ich am Millerntor bin, das klingt auch echt finster, aber die Kinder oder die ganz kleinen oder jungen Menschen sind vorne am Zaun. Genau, richtig. Lass mal die Kleinen nach vorne. Und das ist so, das wurde mir nachher erst bewusst, ja klar, natürlich schlimm.
Es ist der Wahnsinn. Und wir haben schon im Intro gehört Bruce Grobbela, den Torhitter vom FC Liverpool, der eben damals dann gesagt hat, das war der Ohtund, den ihr auch im Intro gehört habt, die Leute haben geschrien und haben ihn um Hilfe gebeten. David, the killing us, so wie er es geschrieben hat. Und er hat dann einen Ordner gebeten oder einen Polizisten, da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, könnt ihr den Leuten helfen, könnt ihr das Tor aufmachen? Und derjenige hat das dann verneint. Und das finde ich auch so völlig irre, weil da eben nochmal beides aufeinander trifft. Der Fußball, derjenige, der eigentlich in seinem Tor steht, um Sport zu machen. Und aber diese Tragödie und der dieser Tragödie genauso nahe ist, wie einige Polizisten in seinem Rücken, wie die Fans, die zum Teil in diesem Moment schon tot sind. Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen. Und ich fand aber, habe seinen O-Ton reingenommen, weil er es schafft, da in einer unglaublich würdevollen Art auch davon zu erzählen und darüber zu berichten. Also überhaupt haben sich die Liverpool-Spieler, viele davon sind sehr gut mit dieser Situation umgegangen, nach dem, was ich jetzt so gesehen habe aus alten Zeitdokumenten, was man sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen kann, weil es sind ja eigentlich nur Fußballer.
Ja, gut, damit kann ich immer nicht so viel anfangen. Es sind eigentlich nur Fußballer. Aber sie sind gut damit umgegangen, aber sie hatten auch massive Probleme. John Aldrich zum Beispiel, Stürmer damals, hat damals von einem irischer Stürmer, der aber lange für Liverpool gespielt hat, ihren sind ja in Liverpool nicht gerade unwillkommen. Und der lebt auch bis heute in Liverpool. Ich habe den auch getroffen. Der hat wirklich, also ich verhör mich auf die Goldwaage zu legen, bei so schrecklichen Ereignissen, aber der hat wirklich versucht, oder überlegt seine Karriere zu werden. Kenny Doglish, absolute Vereinslegende, wahrscheinlich die größte Liverpool-Vereinslegende nach oder mit Steven Gerrard, war ja damals Trainer. Der hat angeordnet, dass das gesamte Team zu allen Funerals geht, zu allen Beisetzungen. Es war so zweierlei. Gut mit umgegangen, gebe ich dir total recht, aber die haben auch richtig geknapst. Also logischerweise, das ist jetzt gar nicht so. Aber das war eben zweierlei. Gerade so ein Mensch wie John Aldridge, der die Liverpool DNA in sich trägt, obwohl er in Anführungszeichen ihre ist, hatte damit lange, massive Probleme natürlich.
Ja, ich ärgere mich auch über meine Formulierung. Ich hatte das so gemeint, dass die Sportler ja den Auftrag hatten, Fußball zu spielen. Sie mussten ja dann auch die Saison noch zu Ende spielen. Der ganze sportliche Teil ist dann nochmal so eine besondere Pointe. Sie haben den FA-Cup gewonnen, aber gegen Arsenal im letzten Spiel der Saison. Arsenal kam als Zweitplatzierter zum erstplatzierten Liverpool da dann mit 1 zu 2 verloren. Das ist das Spiel über das – oder 0 zu 2, 0 zu 2 war es glaube ich – über das Nick Hornby geschrieben hat in Fieberpitch. Und eben aber vor dem Hintergrund, dass sie sich nicht vor dieser Tragödie verschlossen haben, in dem Sinne, dass sie gesagt haben, Köpfe nach unten, wir konzentrieren uns aufs Sportliche und trainieren so lange, bis die Saison weitergeht, sondern eben dieser Fakt, den du gerade genannt hast, dass sie auf allen Beerdigungen waren. Und das muss man sich einfach nochmal vor Augen führen, wie groß diese Zahl der 96 Toten damals war. Damals waren es noch erst 94. Dann kam zwei Tage später noch jemand ums Leben und dann ein paar Jahre später jemand, der im Koma lag. Aber das muss ja auch eine unglaubliche Belastung gewesen sein für diese Sportler. So hatte ich es gemeint.
Und mit diesen Menschen, mit diesem Opfer oder späteren Opfer, von dem du gerade sprichst, ich glaube, der dann einige Tage oder zwei Wochen circa später dann verstorben ist, bei dem war John Aldridge. John Aldridge war bei dem tatsächlich am Krankenbett und hat ihm noch versprochen, mit Trikot und ich hätte es fast gesagt, das Übliche und Stadionbesuch. Und der ist dann verstorben. Und das hat John Aldridge bis heute natürlich nicht überwunden.
Und Kenny Dalglish, der Trainer von Liverpool, hat später dann erst in seinen Memoiren irgendwann mal die Geschichte erzählt, dass die Spieler wurden tatsächlich von vielen Familien bei Verletzten, die im Koma lagen, gebeten, ans Krankenbett zu kommen, in der Hoffnung, dass die Präsenz des Stars, also desjenigen, denen die im Koma liegenden so anhimmeln, irgendetwas bewirkt. Und bei Kenny Dalglish soll es wohl tatsächlich so gewesen sein, dass er bei einem sehr jungen Fan am Bett stand und ihm dann gesagt hat, wer er ist und dass er jetzt hier ist und mit ihm geredet hat. Und der wäre tatsächlich da dann aus dem Koma erwacht. Das hat er aber über 15 Jahre lang für sich behalten und erst irgendwann, ich glaube, in seinen Memoiren dann erzählt.
Ja, ich finde diesen Bezug auf Sportliche, wenn man so mit einer gewissen Binnensicht Hillsborough immer so ein bisschen drauf hatte. Wie gesagt, diese Peter Beardsley-Geschichte, Kenny Douglas und so. Das macht das Ganze weder höher noch kleiner noch irgendwas. Nur das war mir alles nicht bewusst und das ist schon einerseits finde ich irgendwie Ehrenwert. Respektive sollte normal sein, wie so eine Mannschaft oder so ein Club damit umgeht. Also direkt danach im Übrigen. Das ist schon bedeutend. Aber das ist auch typisch Liverpool, würde ich so aus meiner Sicht der letzten Wochen und Monate auch sagen. Also weil Liverpool einfach eine relativ kleine Stadt erstmal ist und so ein bisschen auch, hier kennt auch jeder jeden. Und dadurch, wenn es dann 96 Todesopfer und über 700 Verletzte sind, dann ist gefühlt, ich übertreibe jetzt bewusst, jeder betroffen. Jeder. In irgendeiner Weise. Und das ist schon interessant für mich.
Und ich glaube auch nicht nur in übertragender Weise. Also heute hat Liverpool 490.000 Einwohner, habe ich mir gerade rausgesucht. Also direkt die Stadt Liverpool, wie es jetzt 1989 war, weiß ich gar nicht. Aber das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich ein wichtiger Punkt, auch wenn wir dann gleich über das Danach von Hillsborough sprechen. Die familiären oder die Bekanntschaftsverbindung zu Leuten, die im Stadion waren, die gab es halt wirklich bei fast jedem. Und auch deshalb hat sich Hillsborough immer auch als so ein Anäkter, so ein elektrotisches Ereignis gehalten. Also jeder hatte eine Geschichte. Die Geschichten wurden früh aufgeschrieben, erzählt, über die Medien verbreitet. Es gab Bücher dazu. Und ich glaube, das ist kein Zufall, dass man deswegen eben weiß, was so manche Spieler gemacht haben, was viele der Überlebenden gemacht haben, wie welche Dramen es dann da noch im Nachhinein gab. Es gibt ja auch einige Selbstmorde in der Folge von Hillsborough, die mit der Tragödie in Verbindung gebracht werden. Und ich glaube, das hängt aber damit zusammen, weil es nicht in Multimillionenmetropole passierte, sondern eben in einer relativ kleinen Stadt, in der jeder mindestens über einen Bekannten, würde ich vermuten, jemanden kannte, der vor Ort war und der dann da ums Leben gekommen ist, verletzt wurde oder das Glück hatte, Überlebender zu sein und vielleicht sogar unbeteiligter, weil er nicht in diesen in diesen Blöcken stand, sondern woanders im Stadion saß. Und ich glaube, auch daher kommt das, dass es eben so ein anekdotisches Wissen über Hillsborough gibt. Es gibt ein ganzes Buch, nur mit Erlebnisberichten von vor Ort.
Genau, genau. Es ist so diese mittelgroßen Städte, kleine oder Großstädte, Liverpool ist irgendwas dazwischen und man hat das Gefühl, dass es in sich eine sehr starke, stolze Stadt ist, die so einen wahnsinnigen, auch vor Hillsborough schon einen wahnsinnigen Zusammenhalt hatte, dadurch noch verstärkt natürlich. Und dann hat man wirklich das Gefühl, da kennt jeder jeden und dann gibt es diese gewisse Opferzahl, das ist ja fast schon eine mathematische Gleichung und irgendwie hat mir einer gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, das war irgendein Mensch, den ich auch dann, ja, wie es so häufig ist, man kommt ja am besten dann doch im Pub am Abend ins Gespräch und der meinte irgendwie, there's too many stories to be told about Hillsborough, also es gibt viel zu viele Geschichten, die alle in ihrer eigenen Geschichte, ob Spieler, Opfer, Überlebende, Angehörige, Täter vielleicht auch, gibt, das ist Wahnsinn und das meine ich eingangs mit Komplex, Komplex ist immer so ein negatives Wort, ich finde Komplex immer gut, weil es so viel aufzudröseln gibt in dem Sinne, aber das ist Hillsborough letztendlich.
Genau, kommen wir kurz zurück zu dem, was dann passiert ist. Wir hatten diesen Latten-Treffer, der Wellenbrecher bricht, der auch schon sehr alt war, über 60 Jahre. Fans versuchen aus dem Block rauszukommen, werden zum Teil herausgezogen, das sind Bilder, die vielleicht auch der eine oder andere und die eine oder andere von euch da draußen schon mal gesehen hat. Da wurden auch die Fans nach oben in die Blöcke weggezogen und um 15.06, also in der siebten Spielminute, rennt dann ein Polizist aufs Spielfeld Schiedsrichter und bittet ihn, das Spiel zu unterbrechen. Und jetzt passiert etwas Entscheidendes, nämlich das Gerücht beziehungsweise von Dackenfield auch so kommuniziert an die Polizisten, deren Funkgeräte noch funktionierten. Eine Spielfeldinvasion, also eines Platzsturms macht die Runde. Und das sorgt jetzt dafür, dass ganz viele Entscheidungen jetzt falsch getroffen werden. Zum Beispiel eins von hunderten Beispielen. Es gab Feuerwehrmänner, die Schneidewerkzeuge hatten, um eben zum Beispiel den Zaun aufzumachen, weil das Tor ja nicht besonders breit war, dass man jetzt dann vorne aufgemacht hat. Denen wurde erstmal verboten, aus Spielfeld zu gehen. Oder die Fans, die jetzt vor allem zusammen mit den wenigen vor Ort anwesenden Sanitätern erste Hilfemaßnahmen angebracht haben, die haben sich dann aus Werbebanden tragen gebastelt, weil nicht genügend Krankenwagen vor Ort waren und mussten sich zum Teil noch ihren Weg durch eine Polizeikette bahnen, die errichtet wurde über den Platz, um eben ein Zusammentreffen von Liverpool und Nottingham Forest-Fans zu verhindern. Also völlig chaotische Szenen, aber noch chaotischer als es hätte sein müssen bei so einer Tragödie. Und das hat eben damit zu tun, mit der Angst des, was du vorhin auch gesagt hast. Diese Erfahrung des Platzsturmes, und das eben einfach viele Beteiligte noch bis relativ weit nach Spielabbruch tatsächlich dachten, hier läge ein Platzsturm vor. Und das war auch die Information, die schon um Viertel nach drei dann an die Medien weitergegeben wurde. Und das hat nochmal ganz fatale Folgen gehabt, glaube ich.
Völlig richtig, was dann vier Tage später in dieser The Truth Headline der Boulevardzeitung The Sun mündete. Und noch mal kurz einen Schritt zurück. Ich habe mit einer meiner – die gehören mir nicht – einer der Überlebenden, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, hat einen Polizisten gerufen. Der hat ihn durch den Zaun gerufen und hat gesagt, ihr müsst etwas tun, also hier sterben Leute unter mir. Und dann hat der Polizist zu ihm gesagt, get back, get back, also geh zurück. Und der sagt, ich kann mich überhaupt nicht bewegen. Ich kann mich nicht bewegen, ich kann überhaupt nicht zurück. Also es muss auch zu Dialogen, weil du vorhin auch Bruce Grobbela ansprichst, das finde ich wahnsinnig bewegend, dass ein Torhüter von seinen eigenen Fans gerufen bekommt, Bruce, kannst du uns bitte retten, weil die Authorities, die Verantwortlichen, retten uns scheinbar nicht. Was ist das für eine unfassbare, also allein vom Dialog her schon so unfassbar. Aber es gab auch sehr viele, ich habe auch Bilder gesehen, wie Fans in den ersten Reihen Polizisten anschreien und sagen oder rufen, holt uns hier raus. Und natürlich, wenn von oben der Befehl kommt, nein, oder auch die Verweigung kommt mit den Bolzenschneidern, oder was das auch immer, ja, Bolzenschneider vermutlich, nein, wir machen die Tore nicht auf, dann folgen gewisse Polizisten diesem Befehl.
Ja, und das führt eben dann dazu, dass die Ersthelfer zu großen Teilen eben auch Fans des FC Liverpool sind, also die in den umstehenden Blöcken versuchen, rauszuziehen, wen sie rausziehen können. Irgendwann reißen sie mit bloßen Händen einen der Zäune nieder und helfen. Und eben auch die Ersthilfe wird von vielen Fans übernommen, denn im ganzen Stadion waren insgesamt 30 Sanitäter der St. John's Ambulance. Das ist eine Organisation, die vor allem von Freiwilligen betrieben wird. Fünfte Helfer. Und die bieten eben ihre Dienste für solche Großveranstaltungen gegen Spenden an. Und weil das günstiger war als andere Lösungen, haben das damals eigentlich alle Clubs in England dann so gemacht. Hat eben dazu geführt, dass es eben 30 Sanitäter insgesamt waren. Fünfte Helfer davon waren blutige Anfänger und jünger als 14 Jahre. Das zeigt, wie die Situation im Stadion war. Und deswegen lag es dann eben bei den Polizisten, die dann unten am Zaun waren und dann auch das Tor geöffnet haben und bei den Fans die Erstversorgung zu übernehmen. Und da kam es zu chaotischsten Szenen, so wie man es sich vorstellen kann. Erstmal musste das Tor geöffnet werden und dann lagen da die Menschen aber so übereinander, dass die Hinteren gar nicht raus konnten. Ich will da jetzt dann eigentlich gar nicht ins Detail gehen, aber ihr müsst euch komplette Verwirrung vor Ort vorstellen. Und was aber wichtig ist, ist das Fehlen von von Ärzten vor Ort, von Notfallsanitätern hat unter anderem auch dazu geführt, dass nicht systematisch festgestellt wurde, welche Verletzungen liegen vor und sind diejenigen, die aus dem Block geholt wurden? Gibt es da noch Lebenszeichen oder nicht?
Und schlichtweg auch so eine, ich will nicht sagen Selbstregulierung, aber Selbsthilfe der Fans, die scheinbar in gewissen Zügen, das soll jetzt nicht zu pauschal klingen, aber in gewissen Zügen früher verstanden haben, was los ist, indem sie Werbebanden rausbrechen, um die als Tragen zu nehmen, wo viele Fans auch im Übrigen dran gehindert wurden. Also die Idee ist bei Weitem keine schlechte, um allein die Menschen abzutransportieren, aus dem Stadion zu kriegen. Es wurden ja wirklich Menschen auf diesen Werbebanden, also letztendlich auf Tragen, durch den Kabinentunnel rausgetragen. Also die sind an den Spielern, die standen da ja auch ein bisschen, ja geht es jetzt noch weiter, die wussten auch nicht, und an denen vorbei, in dem Spielertunnel, haben sie auf Werbebanden bewusstlose rausgetragen, wo sie auch erst noch dran gehindert wurden. Also es war immer so eine, scheinbar immer so eine Angst, immer noch von den Authorities, obwohl die Lage so schlimm war, immer noch – Moment, dürfen wir das zulassen? dürfen die hier mit einer Trage, mit einem halbleblosen Körper oder leblosen Körper überhaupt durchgrade? Also das ist so ein Kontext 89, den ich nicht begreifen kann oder viele wahrscheinlich nicht, aber so war es scheinbar, dass immer noch selbst in dieser großen Not die Verantwortlichen, die Sicherheit, den Eindruck hatten, wir müssen immer noch gucken, dass uns das hier nicht aus dem Ruder läuft. Dabei war es längst aus dem Ruder gelaufen.
Ja, und führte eben auch dazu, dass es keinerlei Ordnung in dieser Erstversorgung gab. So schwierig, dass so oder so herzustellen ist, aber zum Beispiel gab es niemanden ganz lange Zeit, der vor Ort war, der feststellen konnte, welche der Verletzten müssen jetzt sofort ins Krankenhaus, welche sind schon tot, welche sind nur weniger verletzt und müssen nicht sofort ins Krankenhaus. Also das ist das, was ja Notfallretter vor Ort bei so Massenunglücken mit als Erstes machen müssen, diese Priorisierung vorzunehmen. Und es kam eben, das weiß man jetzt im Nachhinein, auch ganz zu fatalen Fehleinschätzungen. Also es gibt Gerüchte, wobei da muss man bei Hillsborough sehr vorsichtig sein, aber angeblich hätten sogar Leute mit Lederhandschuhen an der Hand, Polizisten, den Puls geführt. Würde ich jetzt aber mal sagen, in der Panik-Situation kann das vielleicht sogar passieren. Aber definitiv wurden nicht die richtigen Maßnahmen getroffen, weil alle Fans, die da Verletzungen erlitten hatten, mehr oder weniger die gleichen Symptome, nämlich Atemnot. Und dann wurden die meisten rückwärts auf den Rücken gelegt, auf diese Wärbebanden oder aufs Feld. Und das ist das Schlechteste, was du dann machen kannst. In einer stabilen Seitenlage hat der Körper viel mehr Möglichkeit, vielleicht doch noch irgendwie Sauerstoff in sich hinein zu bekommen. Also man will sich auch da eigentlich gar nicht mit den Details so genau auseinandersetzen, weil es einfach – bitter ist da ein komisches Wort für, aber mir fällt jetzt kein anderes zu ein – aber es tut einem einfach weh, im Nachhinein zu sehen, selbst zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wo schon so viel Schlimmes passiert ist, hätte aber noch mit einer besseren Organisation vor Ort so vielen geholfen werden können. Also ganz, ganz viel später, im Jahr 2014 war das dann, hat man dann festgestellt, 41 der 96 Toten hätten vermutlich durch eine bessere Erstversorgung noch gerettet werden können.
Richtig, richtig. Das wurde 2014 festgestellt, was für viele nichts bringt, einerseits. Also für die Toten schon mal gar nicht, aber ich meine damit eher die Angehörigen. Aber es war diese Nachricht 2014 war für viele ein absoluter, später Sieg. Ich versuche das richtige Wort zu finden. Wahrscheinlich gibt es das richtige Wort dafür nicht. Aber es war für viele wahnsinnig wichtig, weil ich habe mit Angehörigen gesprochen, die hauptsächlich ihre Söhne verloren haben. Der Jüngste, haben wir vorhin glaube ich schon gesagt, war zehn. Es sind ja hauptsächlich junge Männer grob im Bereich um die 18 bis 25, jetzt so eine Mitte dort finden zu wollen, wenn es überhaupt möglich ist. Und davon gibt es natürlich viele Eltern, die bis heute 30 Jahre danach immer noch damit zu kämpfen haben. Einige, die ich mit einigen Müttern gesprochen habe, die haben mir gesagt, unsere Söhne sind eben zweimal gestorben. Also nicht nur einmal rein physisch, wenn ich es so richtig verstanden habe. Das Gauseenglisch ist auch nicht so einfach zu verstehen, aber das meine ich jetzt gar nicht. Einerseits physisch, aber auch ein zweites Mal in dem Bewusstsein, die wurden alleingelassen. Eigentlich sogar ein drittes Mal, als gesagt wurde, fünf Tage später, vier Tage später von der Sun und auch dann Teil, ja eigentlich auch juristisch, Tod durch Unfall. Also eine Mutter hat wirklich zu mir gesagt, mein Sohn ist dreimal gestorben.
Ich habe die Zahlen sogar vor mir. Also 38 Tote waren zwischen 10 und 19 Jahre jung und 40 zwischen 20 und 29 Jahren. Das heißt 78 der 96 fallen eben in dieses Alter von 10 bis 29 Jahren. Das ist die Zahl zu dem, was du geschildert hast. Es passiert jetzt noch ganz viel. Die Turnhalle am Stadion wird zu einer improvisierten Leichenhalle umfunktioniert. Die meisten Entscheidungen werden jetzt von erfahreneren Polizisten vor Ort getroffen, nicht von Dackenfeld selbst. Es gibt dann in dieser Turnhalle einen Bereich für die Toten und einen für die Verletzten. Aber die Unterscheidungen nahm damals noch kein Arzt vor. Der kam nämlich erst irgendwie um viertel vor vier an und hat dann innerhalb von 25 Minuten bei 20 Personen den Tod festgestellt. Und am Ende kamen von den 96, die starben nur 14, ins Krankenhaus und nur zwei von ihnen waren bei der Ankunft noch leben. Alle anderen waren dead on arrival. Und vor allem ein Fall warf dann sehr viel später Fragen auf, nämlich der von Eddie Spirit. Der wurde kurz nach 15 Uhr bewusstlos. Aber erst um 17 Uhr wurde notiert, dass er in einem Krankenhaus ankam und wo er zwischendurch war, er hat überlebt, ist völlig unklar und hängt aber sehr wahrscheinlich mit diesem Chaos zusammen. Und es gibt verschiedene Theorien. Es kann sein, dass er als Tod identifiziert wurde und in der Turnhalle lag. Es kann sein, dass er zwischen den Krankenhäusern hin und her gefahren wurde. Es gab auch einen fürchterlichen Stau, der insgesamt dann 42 Krankenwagen, die dann gerufen wurden, der Notfallplan in den Krankenhäusern wurde erst viel zu spät in Kraft gesetzt. Deswegen waren auch die beteiligten Kliniken völlig überfordert. Also dieses Schicksal zeigt, bebildert nochmal das, was ich beschrieben habe. Viele hätten mit einer besseren Erstversorgung noch gerettet werden können. Und auch deshalb ist die Zahl der Toten so hoch, weil das völlig chaotische Zustände waren.
Und einer, den ich getroffen habe, namens Peter Carney, ein Überlebender, der ist heute 59, also er war damals dementsprechend 29. Der war 40 Minuten im Koma, also weil du gerade jemanden ansprichst, der bei dem… Es gibt einfach auch viele dort, die Überlebenden, die gar nicht wissen, was mit ihnen war, wie sie gerettet wurden. Teilweise wurden sie… Man kann sich das… Also er hat mir das so erklärt, dass man sich das wie heute auch so, wie sagt man, auf den Konzerten, auf den Festivals, wenn Leute so über die Arme, über die Hände getragen werden, so vermutet er bis heute, wurde er nach hinten gereicht. Und er hat nur noch so, so schemenhaft was vor sich, wie er das spürt, dass er so über die Menge gehoben wird, nach hinten. Er weiß nicht, wer das getan hat. Natürlich ist es auch eine Menge an Menschen, die ihn gerettet haben. Aber er sagt natürlich, gerne würde er wissen, wer das, ich sag mal jetzt mal hauptsächlich mitgetragen hat, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Aber davon gibt es ganz viele, denen einfach logischerweise durch komatöses Dasein Zeit fehlt.
Ja, und man muss, das ist zwar jetzt so eine La Pali, aber das muss hier einmal noch kurz gesagt werden, wir sind im Jahr 1989, das heißt keine Mobiltelefone und eben ganz schwieriges Finden derjenigen, die das überlebt haben. Und dann im Nachgang dieser Katastrophe rennst du dann irgendwann zu dem Treffpunkt, den du vorher ausgemacht hast. So musste man das ja dann damals machen. Und da warten die Fans dann zum Teil stundenlang, ob ihre Freunde kommen. Manchmal kamen sie alle, manchmal hat einer gefehlt, oder du bist zum Bus gelaufen und von allen. Alle waren da bis auf den Jüngsten in der Gruppe. Und dann ging auf einmal die Frage los, wo ist er, wie können wir ihn finden, wie können wir die Eltern erreichen. Die Notfallnummern, die dann übers Fernsehen eingeblendet wurden, waren völlig überlastet. Deswegen konnten die die Angehörigen aus Liverpool, die wussten, dass jemand aus ihrem Umfeld vor Ort im Stadion ist, die haben nichts erfahren. Es gab keine ordentlich geführten Listen der Toten, was zu ganz fürchterlichen Identifizierungsmaßnahmen in dieser Turnhalle geführt hat. Also, das war dann so die Tragödie nach der Tragödie. Nicht nur die Kommunikation darüber, da können wir nicht gleich noch kurz drüber sprechen, sondern dann auch der Umgang mit denjenigen, die vor Ort Angst hatten, jemanden verloren zu haben und denjenigen, die dann aus Liverpool irgendwann rübergefahren sind, weil sie keinerlei Kontakt zu irgendwelchen Institutionen bekommen haben. Und da sind dann noch mal fürchterliche Geschichten passiert. Unter anderem in dieser Turnhalle, wo dann in einem Bereich die Toten lagen, in einem Bereich haben die Polizisten gegessen. Alles nur abgetrennt durch herunterhängende Tücher in so einer großen Turnhalle. Und im letzten Bereich der Halle war dann der Bereich, wo du verhört wurdest tatsächlich, wenn du einen Familienangehörigen identifizieren konntest anhand erst von sehr schlecht ausgeleuchteten Polaroid-Bildern, die dann alle aufgehängt wurden. Die musste man sich dann angucken und hat dann eventuell jemanden identifizieren können. Und dann war es eben nicht so, dass du Abschied nehmen konntest, sondern direkt nach der Identifizierung wurde der Leichnam wieder weggebracht und dann wurden die Fans verhört. Und da kommen wir jetzt nämlich dann zum Bereich der Kommunikation. Diese Verhöre, die dann irgendwann zwischen neun Uhr und bis zum Mittag am nächsten Sonntag stattgefunden haben in der Turnhalle, die liefen alle unter einem Grundthema, nämlich könnte es nicht gewesen sein, dass der Verstorbene oder die Verstorbene betrunken gewesen sei. Also wie viel hat sie denn normalerweise getrunken? War er noch vorher in einem Pub? Haben sie ihn gesehen mit Alkohol? Also es wurde hier nicht die Identifizierung dann letztlich erfragt, das was die Angehörigen erwartet haben, sondern da begann dann schon, dass die Polizei versucht hat eine Geschichte zu bilden, ein Narrativ zu entwickeln, das diese Tragödie erklärt und auch von der Verantwortlichkeit der Polizei ablenkt.
Ja und ein Narrativ schlichtweg, was in die Zeit passte. Wenn man mal ganz zynisch ist, haben sie es so unklevernicht gemacht, um direkt von ihren eigenen Verfehlungen, die ja sehr viel später eingeräumt, fast bewiesen wurden, haben sie die Zeit genutzt, haben sie die Medien benutzt oder auch umgekehrt, um zur Sun-Schlagzeile zu kommen. Margaret Thatcher war Fußball an sich ein Dorn im Auge. Die Folgen kennen wir, keine Stehplätze mehr. Kann man lange diskutieren, ob das der richtige oder falsche Entscheid an sich war, aber sie hat es bereits vorgehabt. Heißt, ganz überspitzt formuliert, ich mag den Satz kaum aussprechen, kam für manche Hillsborough nicht zum falschen Zeitpunkt, um gewisse Dinge umzusetzen.
Ja, da würde ich auch voll zustimmen. Das verdeutigt vielleicht auch noch eine Maßnahme, die auch zeigt, wie wenig Skruppel man da hatte von Seiten der Behörden. Der zuständige Gerichtsmediziner, Dr. Steven Popper, der hat dann entschieden, als ab halb 10 Uhr abends die Identifizierung der Toten begann, von jedem Toten Blut für einen Alkoholtest abzunehmen, auch von dem zehnjährigen Jungen, was völlig unüblich ist, auch nicht moralisch höchstverwerflich und ich glaube auch nicht unbedingt legal.
Und das zeigt ja schon. Ja und natürlich, also Samstagnachmittag, FA-Cup Halbfinale, Liverpool gegen Nottingham Forest, 1989, wer geht da, vielleicht ein zehnjähriger nicht, und das fände ich auch noch gerade gut, oder normal in Anführungszeichen, wer geht da vorher nicht in den Pub und trinkt drei Pints? Also das ist es doch auch. Sie haben es versucht, sie ist immer nur ein dores Wort, aber gewisse Gruppierungen oder Institutionen haben versucht, das sehr stark einzubetten, um von sich selber abzulenken, ganz einfach.
Genau und auch ein bestehendes Narrativ zu bilden. Es kam dann übrigens später raus, dass ein Sechstel der 96 Fans Alkohol im Blut hatte. Das wurde dann auch, also der Verteidiger der Angehörigen dachte, das wäre ein Argument pro Fans, aber tatsächlich haben es die Medien dann eher in die andere Richtung gedreht und gesagt, wir haben es euch doch die ganze Zeit schon gesagt. Und wie sich das alles entwickelt hat, auch diese Sanschlagzeile, da ist jetzt eben auch nochmal dieser Dackenfied wichtig, der eben die polizeiliche Arbeit vor Ort geleitet hat. Denn der hat schon eine Viertelstunde nach Anpfiff, also um 15.15 Uhr, hat er zwei Vertretern von der FA gesagt, es habe einen Platzsturm gegeben. Und so kam diese Meldung an die Medien. Das dachten dann auch deshalb unter anderem nicht nur die Polizisten vor Ort und haben sich falsch verhalten im Stadion, sondern auch viele im Stadion. Erst um 16 Uhr gab es dann, glaube ich, eine Ansprache von Kenny Dalglish, in der er es aufgeklärt hat, in dem es dann auch Bekundungen von Nottingham Forests Seite gab, die die Liverpool-Fans unterstützt haben. Aber fast bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt gab es auch immer noch einige im Stadion, obwohl man auf dem Platz sehen konnte, dass da Menschen wieder belebt werden, die das falsch gedeutet haben. Die das gedeutet haben in eine Richtung, das geschieht euch selber recht, wenn ihr den Platz stürmen wollt oder wie auch immer, aber so ungefähr in diese Richtung. Und das ist auch die Basis, glaube ich, dafür, dass diese Umstände so verdreht werden konnten und es dann eben zu dieser Zanschlagzeile kommt, wenn du mich fragst.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt. Und was du sagst, diese Erwartung des Platzsturms oder die Interpretation des Platzsturms belegt sich darin auch, dass Nottingham Forest-Fans, einige zumindest, auch auf den Platz gingen, weil sie dachten – und das ist dann auch wieder die Zeit – jetzt geht's ab, jetzt müssen wir auch auf den Platz. Also nicht viele, aber einige Nottingham Forest-Fans dachten, okay, jetzt wollen die auf uns zu. Also auch das zeigt das auf so einer anderen Ebene, dass damals ein Platzsturm scheinbar Usos war. Und wenn es dann einer war, dann müssen wir auch drauf.
Das bringt uns dann eben zu der Sun. Wir haben es schon angesprochen. Die kam dann raus mit der Schlagzeile. Und man muss dazu sagen, das ist Englands größte Boulevardzeitung von Rupert Murdoch, also im Besitz von Rupert Murdoch. Die Schlagzeile war The Truth und darunter dann drei Bullet-Points – ich übersetze sie mal gleich. Einige Fans haben von den Toten gestohlen. Einige Fans haben auf die Brave, also auf die heldenhaften Polizisten uriniert. Einige Fans hätten Polizisten geschlagen, während die den Kiss of Life geben wollten, also Mund zu Mund Beatmung vollzogen hätten. Das war die Überschrift der Sun, die auch nicht zufällig entstanden ist. Das fand ich ganz interessant. Im Nachhinein haben das dann Mitarbeiter von der Sun berichtet, dass der zuständige Redakteur Calvin McKenzie eine halbe Stunde lang über der Überschrift gebrütet habe und dann aus You Scum, also ihr Abschaum, The Truth gemacht hätte. Und damit war das narrativ gesetzt, eben auch mit diesem Anspruch, so war es und nicht anders.
Also auf die Idee, ich finde es so, in dem Artikel oder in diesen Unterüberschriften, also The Truth steht ja oben und dann haben die, ich krieg sie jetzt nicht englisch genau hin, aber behinderten die Arbeit, also Fans behinderten die Arbeit der Brave Cops, also der mutigen Polizisten. Das ist auch so allein schon von der Wortwahl so sehr klar, was da gewollt war und dann diese, wie man sich ausdenken kann und das ist ja Fakt, dass es ausgedacht ist, zu sagen, es hätten welche auf die Brave Cops uriniert. So, da steht er ja. Und das haben halt die Menschen, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, also ferner der Entrüstung an sich, ist das ja nahezu grotesk. So was, gut, wir sind auch im Bereich der Boulevard-Medien, wir haben auch ein Blatt in Deutschland, welches sich auch hier und da Dinge erlaubt, wo man nur Kopfschütteln dastehen kann. Aber das ist in so einer Situation, wo 96 Menschen umgekommen sind, ist schon heavy und daraus resultiert ja dieser seit 30 Jahren sehr stark bestehende Boycott der Sun in Liverpool. Ich habe immer so ein bisschen gedacht, auch das sei eine – wie soll ich sagen – vielleicht doch eine urbane Legende, eine Mythologisierung, eine Rebellion, die nach außen getragen wird, in Reiseführern, in irgendwelchen Fußballkultur-Magazinen und in so geilen Podcasts wie diesem besprochen wird. Nein, es ist wirklich da. Es ist wirklich da. Ich habe ganz, ganz viele, nicht nur mitten im City-Center, sondern – ja gut, Anfield ist eh klar, also wo das Stadion ist – aber ich habe immer wieder Zeitungsstände gesucht, bewusst gesucht, um das Gegenteil vielleicht mal irgendwo zu erfahren. Du findest keine Sun. Überall Daily Mirror, Guardian und sowieso, die Serien Daily Mirror, Mail und so weiter da. Sun findest du nicht. Habe ich zumindest nicht gefunden. Das ist schon ganz spannend. Im Übrigen dürfen Sun-Reporter nach wie vor in Melwood, also im Trainingsgelände des FC Liverpool. Jürgen Klopp führt das ja auch, ich würde mal sagen, recht forschfort nicht willkommen, schlecht weg. Das ist dann auch im umgekehrten Sinn, ohne dem Bogen jetzt zu weit zu spannen und zu weit weg von unserem Thema zu kommen. Aus Journalistensicht, mit der Pressefreiheit, ja, nach 30 Jahren, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, ich meine, es zeigt halt verschiedene Aspekte. Also zum einen zeigt es, wie schlimm diese verbreitete Lüge war, auch in der Art und Weise. Also die Auflage der Sun fiel ja dann sofort von 400.000 verkauften Ausgaben in Liverpool auf 15.000. Also quasi nicht mehr im messbaren Bereich, würde man heutzutage sagen. Weil eben auch die Bürger in Liverpool und Bürgerinnen ja diejenigen waren, die als Einzige lange wussten, dass das eben alles Lügen sind. Denn für viele andere hat sich ja das Bild von Hillsborough, das war ja das Narrativ und das war zwar besonders krass formuliert von der Sun, aber in Liverpool selbst wusste man am besten, dass das nicht stimmt, weil eben jeder irgendwie einen Bekannten, eine Bekannte vor Ort hatte und das abgleichen konnte durch persönliche Erfahrung und auch ein bisschen gesunden Menschenverstand. Das ist das eine, was es zeigt. Und zum anderen zeigt es aber ja auch einfach, wie Liverpool tickt und wie aufgeladen vor allem auch immer noch diese Debatte ist jetzt das falsche Wort. Aber dieses Unglück wird nicht unemotional betrachtet, was jetzt nicht zynisch verstanden werden soll. Natürlich muss man sowas auch emotional betrachten, aber auch in der sachlichen Auseinandersetzung damit. Also wenn du dann eben die Entscheidung triffst, werden wir jetzt Sun-Reporter von heute, die mit damals nichts mehr zu tun haben, bestrafen wir die dann journalistisch dafür, dass wir ihnen den Zugang zu verwehren. Auch diese Entscheidungen werden immer noch emotional getroffen und ich glaube, das hängt nicht nur damit zusammen, wie krass eben das war, wie die Sun sich da verhalten hat, sondern es hängt auch damit zusammen, wie ungerecht all das war, was jetzt in den folgenden 15 bis 23 Jahren passiert mit der Aufarbeitung von Hillsborough.
Genau. Aber auch da hast du ja auch schon angedeutet, die DNA von Liverpool auch nicht vergessen werden. Also ich weiß nicht, ob Wagenburg-Mentalität so das Richtige ist, aber wenn du so ein schlimmes Ereignis hast und 96 Todesopfer und über 700 Verletzte hast und im Übrigen das Team danach ja auch nicht mehr performt hat. Also wir werden 1990 nochmal Meister, aber Liverpool war zu dem Zeitpunkt das Team schlechthin in England. 1990 ist aber die letzte Meisterschaft. Ein Jahr danach haben sie nochmal performt, danach nicht mehr. Deshalb ist ihnen auch im Übrigen dieses Jahr im 30. Jahr der Katastrophe auch enorm wichtig, vielleicht den Titel noch zu holen, das ist noch am Rande. Aber die DNA Liverpools ist, alle hassen uns, alle wollen uns was. Also ich überspitze jetzt bewusst. Alle hassen uns, alle wollen uns was. Wir gehören eh nicht so ganz zu England. Wir sind eher eine irischen Küste. Wir gucken als einzige so richtig aufs Meer. Ja, solche Sätze habe ich gehört. Und im Übrigen auch Sätze, wenn England spielt. Und nicht von wenigen sind wir nicht für England. Wir sind nicht England. Also das muss man alles auch so ein bisschen in dieser ganzen Gemengelage, die ich vorher so, ich kenne sie immer noch nicht genau, aber ich kenne mittlerweile Strömungen und Tendenzen, möchte ich mal vorsichtig sagen. In dieser Gemengelage, sich dann zusammen zu tun und zu sagen, nee, die Son nicht. Ich habe mit George Sefton gesprochen, mit The Voice of Anfield. Ein unfassbarer Mensch. Ein ganz toller Mensch, der fünf Bücher schreiben sollte. Er schreibt leider erst gerade sein erstes, aber er ist seit 1972 Stadionsprecher in Anfield. The Voice of Anfield heißt er deshalb. Der sagt mir, das ist ein ganz friedfertiger, älterer, wahnsinnig kluger, loyaler Mensch. Der sagt zu mir, wenn er in einer Tube oder einem Bus jemanden sieht mit der Son, geht er hin und sagt, der schlägt ihm die nicht aus der Hand, hat er mir gesagt. Aber er sagt, wissen Sie eigentlich, was Sie da lesen? Nur mal so, das ist ein ganz, wirklich ein ganz lieber Mensch. Das ist so tief drin und ich versuche das wirklich, ich hoffe, es gelingt mir halbwegs wertfrei zu sagen. Aber es ist auch eine in sich getragene Stärke und eben dementsprechend Ablehnung dieser Zeitung, die so lange schon da ist, die ich, ich sag mal mindestens überraschend, überraschend ist vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber schon extrem finde, so möchte ich es mal vorlesen.
Also es ist ein eigener Schlag Mensch, der da in dieser Region wohnt. Also Liverpool war immer eine der wichtigsten Hafenstädte fürs gesamte Commonwealth. Auch deswegen war Liverpool immer ein bisschen internationaler als ganz viele andere englische Städte. Man hatte eben immer schon mit Immigration zu tun, gerade viele Iren, hast du ja vorhin auch schon mal kurz erwähnt, leben in Liverpool. Und gleichzeitig war es aber auch so, es ist eine Arbeiterstadt, also in dem Sinne, dass durch den Hafen zwar große Reichtümer erwirtschaftet wurden, aber die sind in die Hände von einigen wenigen gefallen. Also es gab einige wenige sehr reiche Liverpooler und heute hat sich das Ganze sowieso noch mal ein bisschen gedreht. Aber auch zur damaligen Zeit war es so, es gab eine breite Arbeiterschicht, die nicht nur arm war, sondern dann eben auch sehr unter den Reformen unter Margaret Thatcher gelitten hat und das ist so ein bisschen das Milieu, in dem sich die Liverpooler bewegen. Wobei mich da jetzt mal interessieren würde, wie dein Eindruck jetzt vom heutigen Liverpool war, ob das noch da dazu passt.
Ich kenne das damalige natürlich nicht, aber ich kenne es durch Recherchen und durch Bilder von damals natürlich. Also ich würde es mal so sagen, um Anfield herum, was jetzt nicht Liverpool City Center ist, da denkst du schon, scheiße ist das abgeranstiert. Ich mag das im Übrigen sehr, ich mag unverputzte, backsteinartige, viktorianische, fast schon verfallene Häuser, also da denkst du, alter Schwede, das ist aber krass. Und wenn du dann den Bus ankommen siehst, mit Naby Caters, die für 60 Millionen oder Bobby Firminium, du weißt, was ich sagen will, diese Amplitude, die jetzt ein bisschen boulevardesk daherkommt, dann ist das schon irgendwie interessant. Also Anfield ist wirklich ein wahnsinnig romantisches Drecksloch, finde ich, also das Viertel. Ich bin da sehr gerne, meine ich ernst. Also die Merseyside selber am Fluss unten, da haben sie unheimlich viel Geld reingebuttert. Letztendlich, die Stadt sind auch die Beatles. Also damit wird natürlich auch, also der Airport heißt natürlich John Lennon Airport und so weiter. Was ich sagen will ist, an der Merseyside, deshalb komme ich drauf, gibt es für mich viel zu viele Fab Four-Museen, Fab Four Dies und Dies. Da wird natürlich die Tourismuskeule geschwungen. Das kenne ich aus Hamburg nicht anders, du aus München genauso. So sind solche Städte heutzutage oder schon lange. Da haben sie in Liverpool auch richtig dran geschraubt. Das ist schon so. Aber dennoch, der Menschenschlag und auch das Stadtbild ist immer noch ein raues. So möchte ich es mal sagen, ja.
Und eben dieser Kontrast zwischen der Armut und dem Reichtum, den konntest du in Liverpool sehen und den sieht man jetzt heute eben in deiner Schilderung noch, wenn der Liverpooler Mannschaftsbus durch dieses Viertel fährt. Und damals war es aber noch heftiger. Also Anfang der 80er Jahre waren die Arbeitslosenrate mit einer der höchsten im ganzen United Kingdom. 17 Prozent waren es im Januar 1982. Das war der Höchstwert. Und so schlimm stand es um die Arbeitslosigkeit in Liverpool nur 50 Jahre davor während der großen Depression. Also das holt uns eben wieder zurück in diese 80er Jahre. Bis 1989 hat sich da wieder ein bisschen was getan. Aber wir reden eben von mehrheitlich armen Menschen, für die der Fußball dann eben sehr viel auch bedeutet und dieser Verein auch viel bedeutet. Und die sich dann eben ungerecht behandelt sehen in Folge jetzt eben der Hillsborough-Tragödie. Und damit würde ich gerne mal zu dem kommen, was jetzt dann nach der Tragödie passiert ist. Jetzt mal abgesehen von den Kampagnen, die in den Medien gefahren wurden, gab es ja auch schon sehr früh Untersuchungen, bei denen man hoffen konnte, erwarten konnte eigentlich, dass vom politischen, von juristischer Seite aus diese Vorfelde sauber aufgearbeitet wurden und dem war aber ganz lange nicht so. Das ging alles los mit dem Taylor Report. Das war ein Richter, der von Margaret Thatcher dazu angewiesen wurde, einen Report zu veröffentlichen. Er hat dann auch schon im August, also im April war das Unglück, schon im August hat er einen Zwischenbericht veröffentlicht und das ist interessant, weil er mit ganz, ganz vielen Vorwürfen an dieser Stelle aufgeräumt hat und das aber in der Folge kaum eine Wirkung hatte. Das alles sollte dann trotzdem noch die nächsten 20 Jahre nicht so wirklich anerkannt werden. Er hat die Hooligan-Vorwürfe ausgeräumt, er hat als zentralen Fehler das Fehlverhalten der Polizei nach dem Öffnen des Tores festgestellt, er hat festgehalten, dass man den Zugang zu den zentralen Blocken hätte verhindern müssen und dass das in der Verantwortung von Dacken fiel klar. Er stellte außerdem fest, dass die Angst vor Hooliganismus eine wesentliche Rolle bei vielen falschen Entscheidungen der Polizei gespielt hatte und außerdem hat er auch Sheffield Wednesday, also eben den Club, der für das Stadion verantwortlich war, wegen der mangelhaften Situation in und um das Stadion herum zur Verantwortung gezogen und er hat auch an diesem frühen Punkt schon Alkoholismus und das Betreten des Stadions ohne Ticket, das war so eine weitere Urban Legend, die sich gebildet hat, dass die Liverpooler Fans sich organisiert hätten, erst spät am Stadion zu erscheinen und dann eben ins Stadion ohne Ticket zu stürmen. Auch das hat er ausgeräumt. Das Einzige, was im Taylor Report noch nicht so gut beleuchtet wurde, war alles, was dann nach der Katastrophe passiert ist. Die Erstretter und alle Institutionen, sowohl die Krankenhäuser als auch die Sanitäter und so weiter, hat er von jeglicher Schuld an den Toten freigesprochen. Da kamen verschiedene Faktoren zusammen, warum er das noch anders gesehen hat. Vielleicht war er da auch an dem einen oder anderen persönlich zu nahe dran. Aber das war der Taylor Report und dann sollte man ja eigentlich glauben, dass damit jetzt dann all diese Lügen, die über Hillsborough kursieren, aufhören. Aber nein, im Grunde war das – also ich kann das jetzt im Nachhinein auch immer noch nicht verstehen, warum der keinen wirklichen Effekt hatte.
Und ich kann auch nicht verstehen, weil wir reden ja über die Jahreszahl 1990 oder 91, eigentlich schon 90, wo dieser Report kam. Und wenn man jetzt mal, ich glaube, den Sprung muss man sogar machen. Wir müssen bis 2009 sogar gehen, wo die erste wirkliche, vernünftige, sagen wir es mal so, unabhängige Untersuchungskommission, wenn man jetzt mal die Zivilklage der Angehörigen von 2000, wo Dackenfeld angeklagt wurde, aber eine Jury keine Urteil finden würde. Bis 2009 hat es gedauert, bis eine wirklich vernünftige Untersuchungskommission, natürlich gebrauchte es auch Geld und Fundraising und so weiter, ins Leben gerufen wurde. Das sind 20 Jahre. Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe es bis heute nicht verstanden, wie sowas so lange dauern kann. Ob manche, weiß nicht, mit diesem Taylor-Report einerseits leben konnten, obwohl das natürlich auch gesagt wurde, wenn ich richtig liege, dass darin auch stand, es war einfach schlichtweg ein Unfall. Also an dieser Bezeichnung Unfall wurde sich ja lange kaum gestoßen. Erst sehr spät eigentlich. Also der Taylor-Report ist schon irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, ich hätte fast gesagt, ein Mischmasch gewesen, der alle irgendwie so ein bisschen entlasten, bewusst nicht belasten, aber alle so, kriegst du nicht hin, aber versuchen sollte, zufriedenzustellen. Und das gelang, so ist meine Deutung, vielleicht liege ich falsch, so ist meine Deutung, weshalb das so lange gedauert hat, bis jemand, nicht nur jemand, sondern eine ganze große Gruppe und eine unabhängige Kommission sich desfalls überhaupt nochmal angenommen hat und diesen Taylor-Report dann schlichtweg 2012 dauernd auch eingesagt hat, also kassiert hat. Ich kann es mir nicht erklären, wie es 18 Jahre dauern konnte. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe auch wirklich viele gefragt und viele sagen, ja, wir wollten Frieden damit machen und irgendwie, ja. Und so richtig Antworten darauf gefunden habe ich leider bis heute nicht.
Dann probiere ich es mal, weil ich habe da natürlich auch viel drüber nachgedacht, ohne jetzt zu viel vorwegzunehmen, was dann auch später noch alles erst rauskommt. Aber man weiß inzwischen, dass vor allem die Polizei schon ganz früh nach dem Unglück daran gearbeitet hat, wie können wir die Verantwortung von uns ablenken. Und da wurden ganz, ganz viele Maßnahmen getroffen. Unter anderem hat man auch mit einer PR-Agentur da zusammen gearbeitet, hat sich schon am Sonntag nach dem Unglück getroffen in einem Café. Das kam dann erst 2016 irgendwann raus aus den ganzen Dokumenten, um eben zu schauen, wie kommen wir bestmöglich aus dieser Situation heraus. Und das hat eben dann unter anderem dazu geführt, dass alle beteiligten Polizisten – und das waren insgesamt dann irgendwas zwischen 1700 und 2000 – wurden aufgefordert, einen Bericht ihres persönlichen Erlebens von Hillsborough zu verfassen. Aber nicht in ihren Notizbüchern, so wie es üblich ist zum damaligen Zeitpunkt bei der Polizei, sondern auf eigenen DIN-A4-Blättern. Die wurden dann gesammelt und wurden dann durchgelesen. Und dann kamen diese Berichte zurück an die Polizisten und es wurden Änderungsvorschläge vorgeschlagen. Zum Teil wurden komplette Sätze gestrichen, zum Teil wurden komplette Seiten rausgestrichen, zum Teil wurde gesagt, also das kannst du so nicht schreiben, schreib das bitte nochmal um. Also an diesem frühen Punkt schon hat die Polizei dafür gesorgt, all das, was kritisch zum Verhalten der Polizei vor Ort bewertet hätte werden können, zu ersetzen durch und die Teile hervorzuheben, die eben auf das Fehlverhalten der Fans drängen. Also eben all die Beobachtungen von Fans, die Alkohol konsumiert haben, von Fans, die vielleicht kein Ticket hatten, all das wurde hervorgehoben, zum Teil sogar wirklich unterstrichen, sprichwörtlich unterstrichen. Und Dinge, die eben das Verhalten der Polizei betrafen, vor allem von Polizisten im Stadion, die dann gesagt haben, wir alle wussten gar nicht, was wir tun sollten, es gab keinen Vorgesetzten von uns, der uns etwas hätte sagen können, wir haben nichts von Dackenfield aus der Box gehört, er hätte das von da oben alles sehen müssen. All das wurde rigoros rausgestrichen. Und ich glaube, weil dieses kriminelle Handeln der Polizei so früh und so perfide und auch so perfekt, zumindest vermeintlich perfekt, angesetzt wurde, konnte es dann eben auch dazu kommen, dass halt verschiedene Untersuchungen, die immer wieder draufgeguckt haben auf die Fakten, die man hatte, dann sehr schnell sagen konnten, nee, es ist so, wie es berichtet wurde und das Fehlverhalten liegt auf Seiten der Fans und alle anderen sind zu entlasten. Ja, und dazu kommt noch ein anderer Grund. Also da muss ich jetzt vielleicht, wenn du magst, dann rausche ich mal kurz durch die verschiedenen Untersuchungen, die es gab. Ich versuche es mal, kurz sein, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Also wir haben den Taylor Report, der eigentlich schon viele Dinge richtig gestellt hat, vor allem die Fans entlastet hat, der aber nicht so wirklich wahrgenommen wurde. Es gab da noch die Verhandlung der Gerichtsmedizin, das ist so ein juristischer Sonderfall. Es muss die Todesursache aller Opfer geklärt werden. Das hat dann eben jener Dr. Popper unternommen in einer Verhandlung in der Gerichtsmedizin, die aber nichts zu tun hat mit einer normalen Verhandlung. Also die Beteiligten haben keine Einsicht in des Teils. Befragte müssen nicht antworten und tun das auch nicht untereilt. Sie könnten also auch lügen. Es gibt keine Schlussplädoyers. Und am Ende, es ist ein Juryentscheid, wie so viele Prozesse in UK. Und am Ende fasst dann Dr. Popper, also der Vorsitzende Gerichtsmediziner, die Beweislage zusammen und gibt eine Empfehlung zu ihrer Entscheidung. Also etwas kurios. Und der hat ein paar kontroverse Entscheidungen getroffen im Vorfeld dieser Verhandlung. Zum einen erachtete er es als erwiesen, dass alle Opfer einen schnellen Erstickungstod gestorben seien und hat deshalb nichts mehr zugelassen in der Verhandlung, was nach 15.15 Uhr passiert war. Wenn Menschen darüber berichten wollten, hat er gesagt, das interessiert uns hier nicht, da waren schon alle tot. Dann ließ er bei Polizeizeugen verkürzte Darstellungen und Meinungsäußerungen zu. Er soll sogar im Rahmen dieser sehr langen Verhandlung – das ging zwei Jahre, von 89 bis 91 – mit Polizisten gefeiert haben. Und die eigentlichen Verantwortlichen, also Dackenfield und Co. mussten sich gar nicht äußern. Und zwei Ärzte, die kritische Berichte zur Erste Hilfe vor Ort verfasst hatten, wurden gar nicht befragt. Und das Ende dieser Verhandlung war, alle Opfer kamen durch einen Unfall zu Tode, was eben dann zur Folge hat, es gibt keine strafprozessrechtliche Verfolgung der Verantwortlichen. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Kern, dass es eben diese Untersuchung gab, die noch keine juristische in dem Sinne ist, dass da ein Prozess stattgefunden hätte, sondern da hat schon jemand drauf geguckt. Und alle anderen, die jetzt dann danach kamen bis zu diesem Panel 2009, die dann 2012 ihre Ergebnisse vorgeschlagen haben, die haben ja alle immer als Grundlage diese gerichtsmedizinische Untersuchung genommen. Und da gab es eben zum Beispiel 1997, 1998, nachdem dann auch ein paar Bücher zum Thema erschienen waren. Und auch die Medien haben da eine interessante Rolle gespielt. Eine Doku, die Anfang Dezember 1996 lief zu Hillsborough, die hat dann zu so viel Öffentlichkeit geführt, dass sich das Parlament fast schon genötigt sah, jetzt nochmal sich das Fals anzunehmen und ein paar unbeantwortete Fragen zu beantworten. Und die haben dann zum Beispiel gesagt, unter Lord Justice Murray Stuart Smith war das dann, also die Stuart-Smith-Untersuchung ist das, der hat gesagt, er guckt sich das nochmal an, aber er wird nur neue Beweise in seine Untersuchung mit einbeziehen. Das heißt, er hat quasi auf dem Kenntenstand von der Popper-Untersuchung nochmal untersucht. Man dachte dann, es hätte neue Beweise gegeben, weil in dieser Doku gab es unter anderem jemanden, einen Techniker, der gesagt hat, die Polizei hat behauptet, die Kamera, die auf den entscheidenden Käfigblock gerichtet war, die wäre kaputt gewesen. Er hat gesagt, nein, die habe ich repariert und ich habe es auch im Kontrollraum gesehen, dass sie da sogar reingezoomt haben und es wären auch Videobänder verschwunden mit Videoaufnahmen von diesen Sicherheitskameras. Der fand in der Doku statt, aber nicht mal er wurde von Stuart Smith mit einbezogen und so kam er dann zu den ähnlichen Ergebnissen wie Popper vorher. Und ich glaube, das ist der eigentliche Grund, weil die Polizei sehr gut darin war, im Ablauf einfach und im Ergebnis ihre Aussagen so zu verdrehen, dass die Verantwortung nicht auf sie gelenkt würde und weil dann die ursprüngliche Untersuchung so oberflächlich war, dass sie zu oberflächlichen Ergebnissen gekommen ist. Und alle anderen bis eben dann zum Jahr 2009, die noch mal draufgeguckt haben, haben immer als Grundlage die Beweislage aus diesem allerersten Fall genommen.
Das ist ja schlichtweg dann das, was 2012 David Cameron, damalige Premierminister, der durch ja in einem Kabinett sehr hochtrabend bei Angehörigen, Freunden und ja hauptsächlich denen entschuldigt, der spricht ja schlichtweg von Verschleierung. Und das ist ja das, was du oder wir gerade versuchen zu erörtern. Das ist schlichtweg ja Verschleierung über, wenn wir den Zeitraum doch wieder versuchen zu fassen, nahezu 20 Jahre war.
Ja, und zum Teil auch bewusst eben also gelenkte Verschleierung. Also man hat ganz bewusst versucht, seine Hände rein zu waschen und ich glaube, da kommt eben dann mit rein, warum konnte das so gut funktionieren, obwohl es den Taylor Report gab, weil es halt auch die Geschichte war, die in die Zeit gepasst hat und weil eben ja diejenigen, die vor Ort waren, denen hat man einfach nicht geglaubt. Die Liverpool-Fans wussten immer, was passiert ist und haben das ja auch sehr, sehr deutlich immer wieder artikuliert und sind wesentlich dafür verantwortlich, dass das dann irgendwann im Jahr 2012, also 23 Jahre nach Hillsborough dass es dann sie freigesprochen wurden von Schuld und es endlich zum ersten Mal eine Untersuchung gehabt, die zu Faktenergebnissen kam und die nicht irgendwelchen Lügen aufgelegen sind. Das lag ja an den Liverpoolern, aber der Rest der Medien und der Rest Englands, der konnte auch diesen anderen Erklärungen glauben, leichter glauben und es passte eben halt auch einfach in die Zeit. Ich glaube daher kommt das und daher kommt vielleicht auch die Verbissenheit, die ich bei den Angehörigen, den Familien der Opfer sehe, die eben über so lange Zeit so viele Dinge unternommen haben, um dieses Thema offen wieder eben zu einer Untersuchung zu bringen, juristisch zu verfolgen, moralischen Druck auszuüben auf Abgeordnete. Das ist ja unglaublich, welche Energie da reingeflossen ist.
Völlig richtig und ich will jetzt nicht sagen der Rest des Landes, aber es gibt – anders formuliert – verfeindete Fußballklubs, speziell Man Utd. ist der größte Rivale von Liverpool FC, die sich seit jeher bis heute im Übrigen über Crying Liverpool lustig machen. Ja, das ist de facto so. Also daraus machen viele Liverpooler auch wieder, ja die stellen uns immer als Heulsusen da. Das hat ja bei Labe nichts mit Heulsusen zu tun, aber natürlich wird der grobe Zynismus auch in den Fußballstadien durch Gesänge und Beschimpfungen getragen, leider Gottes auch in diesem Fall, weil es viel zu tragisch war. Aber da gilt eben das harte Wort, leider. Was ich sagen will ist, viele Liverpooler sagen eben auch, uns wurde eben so lange nicht geglaubt und wir waren angeblich immer die Heulsusen. Und in England darf man ja keine, in Nordengland darf man ja keine Heulsusen im Fußballstadion sein. Daraus wurden sehr viele Chants gebastelt und gebaut. Und jetzt im Übrigen am Sonntag spielt Liverpool gegen Chelsea und am Dienstag war ich noch beim Champions-League-Spiel gegen Porto und habe noch ein paar Leute dort getroffen und die meinten, ja, es gibt am Sonntag eine Schweigeminute, weil am kommenden Montag, also am 15. April, ist der Jahrestag, der 30. Eben, und da wird es eine Schweigeminute geben, eine Minute of Silence, und die werden Trauerflaut tragen und so weiter. Und da meinte einer schon, ja, aber die Chelsea Wankers, natürlich sagen wir es auch, werden die natürlich torpedieren, diese Schweigeminute, weil viele andere, ich sage, versucht das möglichst wertfrei darzustellen, viele andere Clubs können das nicht mehr hören, wollen das nicht mehr hören und sagen, Liverpool, Scouser, Heulsusen, das war mir auch so bisher nicht so klar, dass Liverpool und United sich hassen und Liverpool und Chelsea, das weiß man. Aber es hängt auch viel mit Hillsborough zusammen, mit dieser Genese, dieser ganzen Search for Justice und uns wird nicht recht geben und so weiter. Ja, ja, ihr da oben, ihr Liverpooler. Viele Liverpooler im Übrigen auch, die wollen alle nicht, dass wir dies Jahr Meister werden. Die wollen es nicht, weil das für sie hätte, das einen hochmoralischen, hochpathetischen, hochemotionalen Wert, in diesem Jahr Meister zu werden. Das finde ich in diesem Jahr tatsächlich sportlich mehr denn je eine interessante Frage. Ich will jetzt nicht darüber sprechen, ob Man City oder Liverpool Meister wird, aber das finde ich dies Jahr tatsächlich vor diesem Hintergrund auch spannend.
Ja, das haben ja auch die Liverpooler, mit denen ich zu tun hatte, alle gesagt, dass also dieser Satz, ohne dass ich irgendwie danach gefragt hätte, gefühlt alle fünf Minuten, everybody would hate us if we would win the Championship. Das ist sehr tief verankert. Ich fand da einen O-Ton von Raphael Honigstein sehr gut, der in deiner Doku gesagt hat, auch er hätte das ganz lange nicht verstanden. Er hat es, glaube ich, mit dem Wort Kult, diesen Mythos, der um diese 96 herum aufgebaut wurde, getragen wurde bei Liverpool. So ging es mir lange Zeit auch, dass ich dachte, gut, das ist eine Tragödie, die ist vor langer Zeit passiert, aber warum ist das immer noch so virulent und so aktuell rund um Liverpool? Das kommt aber, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt, einfach daher, weil niemand ihnen glauben wollte und weil im Grunde ganz Liverpool, jeder, der sich mit dem Verein irgendwie identifiziert und vielleicht auch jeder, der in der Stadt lebt, einfach über Jahre hinweg missachtet wurde für für alles Engagement für Hillsborough, zum Teil verspottet wurde und es eben auch zu dieser Rolle passt, in der sich Scouser eben vielleicht auch sehen. Die sehen sich eben als Underdog in ganz England.
Genau, und die Leute mit den, meine Protagonisten, die sagen ja auch, also der eine sagt wirklich, it's like banging your head against the wall for 30 years. Also immer wieder anrennen, immer wieder anrennen. Und sie geben nicht auf, weil die Wunde sie eben so offen klafft, weil du, weil du wenn du 23 Jahre, also schlichtweg ist ja immer noch kein wirkliches Urteil für die wirklichen Verantwortlichen und den wirklichen Verantwortlichen gefällt, wobei das auch eine auch eine schwierige Frage, ob einer wirklich verantwortlich ist, weil auch immer der Name Dackenfeld nicht zu unrecht fällt, aber war er wirklich und so weiter, liegt nicht in meinem Ermessen oder unserem. Aber 23 Jahre, die einhellige Meinung in einem Land, dass man, wenn man Schreckliches miterlebt hat oder jemanden nahen verloren hat, 23 Jahre gilt in einem Land die Meinung, dass die selber daran Schuld waren, dass die Polizei mindestens mal entlastet ist und dass man auch noch viel zu sehr Opferkult betreibt. Diese Wunde kriegst du nicht mehr zu. Würde ich pauschal behaupten. Die kriegst du nicht mehr zu, ohne mich da irgendwie zu positionieren oder so. Das ist ein rein menschlicher Mechanismus aus meiner Sicht. Und deshalb habe ich vorhin versucht, so ein bisschen anzudeuten. Diese Geschichte ist aus meiner Sicht nie juristisch zu klären, weil sie von viel zu krasser, langjähriger Emotionalität geprägt ist. Das kriegst du nicht mehr eingefangen. Und das glaube ich schlichtweg. Das kriegst du nicht mehr mit einem – wenn man Justiz als nicht gesunden Menschenverstand, sondern als eine Art pragmatische Gerechtigkeit versteht – kriegst du diese Geschichte, die so viele, die wir auch versucht haben, bisher zu erörtern, so viele mitunter emotionale, historische, finanzielle oder so kastenwesenartige Parameter, kriegst du die nicht eingefangen, aus meiner Sicht. Und das ist das, weshalb diese Geschichte fortlaufen wird, behaupte ich, ohne jetzt zu sehr den Blick in die Glaskugel zu machen. Aber das glaube ich schlichtweg.
Hattest du denn mit den Organisationen, die sich dann gegründet haben zur Unterstützung der Angehörigen und auch mit den Familien, hattest du mit denen Kontakt im Zuge deiner Recherche?
Ja, hatte ich. Aber sehr einseitig. Oder relativ einseitig, sehr loyal und sehr netten. Aber es gibt eben nach britischem Recht, soweit ich das verstehe, ist auch nicht alles recht kompliziert. Ich habe die Hillsborough Justice Campaign angeschrieben, Margaret Espinal, die – wie soll ich sagen – ich hätte fast gesagt Vorrednerin, der der Opfervereinigung ist. Da haben es viele sehr nett. Auch den Bischof – ich kriege den Namen gerade nicht hin – James Jones. Danke. Auch mir sehr nett geantwortet hat. Aber die wegen des Trials, der seit dem 14. Januar gegen David Duckenfield läuft, der jetzt vor rund zehn Tagen ohne Urteil beendet wurde, aber es wird wahrscheinlich wieder ein Retrial geben, die gesagt haben, nein, wir sprechen nicht. Wir dürfen auch nicht sprechen. Es gibt sogenannte Media Restrictions in England, die aussagen, dass man derzeit wegen dieses Trials – und das hängt auch alles mit der seit 30-jährigen, verworrenen Vorgeschichte zusammen, dass nichts öffentlich erscheinen darf, sei es auf Social Media, sei es im Radio, im Hörfunk, online, TV, wie auch immer – was halbwegs tendenziös sein kann, um die Jury, die vergangene Woche über David Duckenfield entscheiden musste – das war eine 12-köchige Jury, die zu keinem Urteil kam, um das vorwegzunehmen – irgendwie beeinflussen sollte. Ich war sechs Tage in Preston, das ist nördlich von Liverpool. Dort fand der Prozess gegen David Duckenfield statt. Der ist jeden Tag ein- und ausgelaufen und auch diverse Familien und so. Mit denen habe ich dort auch gesprochen, aber immer off-camera, weil die nicht sprechen sollen, nicht sprechen dürfen. Ich hing da blöd gesagt sechs Tage rum und habe auf einen Urteil gewartet. Das kam dann drei Tage später, als ich abgereist war und im Schnitt saß, aber das nur am Rande. Ich erinnere mich an einen Tag, wie das so ist. Gerichtsreporter werde ich in diesem Leben hoffentlich nicht mehr, aber man hängt vor einem Gericht ganz blöd gesagt mit einem Kamerateam rum und wartet, dass irgendwas passiert. Und es passiert und passiert nicht. Und mal holt der BBC-Kollege Kaffee und mal hole ich Kaffee. Und irgendwann, am Freitag Nachmittag, alle sprangen auf, also die Familienangehörigen, die Journalisten, teilweise die Anwälte und so. Jetzt geht irgendwas ab. Und dann hat nur Richter Duckenshaw, so heißt der, der diesen Prozess geleitet hat, hat der Jury gesagt, die sich seit acht Tagen, nein, seit fünf Tagen beriet, und nach acht Tagen haben sie entschieden, dass sie keine Urteile fällen können, keine einstimmiges. Hat der Richter gesagt, und das fand ich ganz freaky, dass sie sich nicht beeinflussen, also er hat zu Jury gesprochen, dass sie sich bitte nicht beeinflussen lassen sollen und am Wochenende keine Zeitung lesen sollen, kein Fernsehen sehen sollen, weil vorausgegangen war ein Tweet einer Angehörigen oder eines Angehörigen, der so sinngemäß gesagt hat, Dackenfeld gehört in Bau oder lebenslängig oder irgendwas. Das soll niemand machen. Also das ist in England viel, viel krasser, also einerseits in dem Fall sehr krass, weil das so eine krasse Vorgeschichte hat, andererseits ist das in England wahnsinnig krass oder wird wahnsinnig kritisch oder eng beäugt, scharf beäugt, was dazu publiziert wird. Egal in welcher Form. Ob du einen gammligen, sag ich jetzt mal so blöd, gammligen Facebook-Kommentar machst oder eine dreistündige Doku in einer BBC. Das soll im Moment nicht gestehen. Das zeigt aus meiner Sicht nur einerseits englisches Recht, andererseits, also anderes Recht als hier, aber andererseits auch, was für ein dünnes Eis diese ganze Thematik mittlerweile nur noch unter sich hat. Das ist so meine Deutung dessen. Aber zurück zu einer Frage, das ist der Grund, weshalb mir viele, also ich finde ja häufig, wie soll ich sagen, es ist häufig besser, off-record-Gespräche für Hintergründe zu bekommen, als wirklich vielleicht dann wirklich das Interview, mal so, mal so, aber das sei jetzt mal eingestellt, aber viele haben mir sehr höflich gesagt, no, we are not allowed und so weiter. Also das war schon tatsächlich schwierig, das war mir auch vorher nicht so bewusst und im Übrigen habe ich, weil du eingangs in einem Intro hattest, Bruce Grobela, den Torhüter damals, den habe ich getroffen irgendwie auf einem meiner Trips nach Liverpool. Toller Typ, auch sehr spannender Typ an sich, erst mal fern von Hillsborough ist das echt ein spannender Mensch, egal, und der auch zu mir sagte, dass der Verein Liverpool, bei dem er ja längst nicht mehr in Lohn und Brot steht, aber den ehemaligen Spielern auch untersagt hat, irgendwas derzeit zu sagen. Ich hatte eine Zusage von John Aldrich, der mit mir vor der Kamera sprechen wollte, sollte, wollte, konnte oder sagte, ja können wir machen, kein Problem, der mir dann auch irgendwann absagte, genau wie John Barnes auch. Ich bekam so reihenweise Absagen aufgrund dieser sogenannten Media Restrictions und die der Verein dann auch mittrug. Im Übrigen, am Montag war eigentlich auch, wie immer, so am St. John's Square, das ist so ein großer Platz in Liverpool, wo damals 2012 auch groß Justice angeprangert wurde und und gesungen wurde und das eben gefeiert wurde, so eine Art Umkehr- oder Entlassung der Pflanz. Da war für Montag auch eine große Feier geplant. Die haben sie abgesagt. Feier ist natürlich falsch, aber eine Gedenkfeier, kann man ja trotzdem sagen, wurde auch abgesagt. Wegen dieses ongoing Trials gegen Duckenfield oder dieses vermeintlichen Reach-Rides, das ist krass sensibel dort, das Thema. Also auch irgendwie in diesem ganzen, ich sag mal, in so medial-juristischen Sinne.
Ja, da habe ich auch meine eigenen Erfahrungen gemacht. Ich habe ja ganz gute Kontakte zu The Enfield Rap, die ja auch unter anderem eigene Podcasts haben, die ich ja auch schon mal hier im Rasenfunk hatte. Und ich habe denen nur rübergeschrieben, hey Jungs, ich will was für Hillsborough machen, könnte ich mit jemandem von euch mal zehn Minuten sprechen. Einfach, dass ihr uns noch mal die Bedeutung erklärt, die es auch heute noch für euch hat. Und dann würde ich das in die Folge reinschreiben. Und dann haben die mir sehr verständnislos und sehr knapp aber auch abgesagt, weil sie gesagt haben, also sorry Max, aber während des Trials können wir gar nichts machen. Das wird auch noch kommen. Ja, irgendwann ganz am Schluss hoffentlich. Aber da war ich auch, erst war ich etwas verwundert, weil die auch wirklich sehr, sehr deutlich waren und ich damit nicht gerechnet hatte. Und als ich mich dann aber mit dem Prozess näher befasst hatte, dann habe ich eben verstanden, okay, das ist einfach so. Und es gab ja, 2000 gab es den ersten Prozess gegen Murray, das war der der Sicherheitschef der Polizei, der mit im Stadion war. Stellvertreter von Duckenfeld, genau. Und eben David Duckenfeld selbst. Und da hat es 22-stündige Beratungen gab es damals. Der Jury, die hat dann Murray als nicht schuldig, er war angeklagt der fahrlässigen Tötung bzw. Manslaughter, ist dann glaube ich Totschlag. Und bei Duckenfeld konnten sie sich nicht auf ein Urteil einigen.
Jetzt auch wieder. Genau.
Das ist jetzt eben 19 Jahre später wieder passiert. Also es ist ja auch eine schwierige Frage. Hast du ja auch schon aufgeworfen. Kann man, also so viele Fehler auch auf ihn zurückzuführen sind und natürlich gibt es eine politische Verantwortung, eine moralische ja sowieso, aber ist es auch eine juristische Verantwortung? Also kann man zweifelsfrei sagen, es lag an seiner Entscheidung, den Tunnel nicht zu sperren, als das Tor geöffnet wurde, dass es zu diesen Toten kam. Nur wenn du unter allen bedenkbaren Umständen, annehmbaren Umständen sagen kannst zu 100 Prozent, ja er war daran schuldig, nur dann darfst du ihn ja verurteilen. Und da kann ich, je länger ich mich damit befasst habe, auch wenn er so ein bisschen der Willen, der Bösewicht in dieser Geschichte ist, du kannst es eigentlich, finde ich im juristischen Sinne nicht auf eine Person eingrenzen.
Das ist ja schlichtweg auch das Hauptargument der Verteidigung in diesem neuen Prozess oder nicht neuen zweiten Prozess kürzlich gewesen, dass sie eben sagen, der kann nicht als einzelner verantwortlich gemacht werden. Genau. Willen passt ganz gut. Ich habe den jeden Tag da in Preston beobachtet, wie er rein und raus ging, hat jeden Tag den gleichen Trenchcoat oder so ein Mantel an. Der kann sehr böse gucken, das muss ich schon sagen. Also mindestens das haut zumindest hin. Aber Spaß beiseite, ich gebe dir da total recht. Es ist wahnsinnig schwierig. Und was du gesagt hast, deine Rückmeldungen auf deine Anfragen bezüglich Hillsborough, ich habe das auch so nicht nur gespürt, aber auch bei – ja, also Mails sind so eine Form der Absage, finde ich, also schriftlicher Form. Aber bei Bruce Grobbler war auch so ein bisschen – hatte ich so den Ahnung, also klar, erstmal war es Bruce Grobbler, der gibt dir die Hand und du hast irgendwie eine Sehenscheideentzündung, das ist das eine. Aber das andere war auch so ein bisschen, als wenn man so einen, wie soll ich sagen, so einen heiligen Ort betritt. Also in dem man so mit Hillsborough reinkommt, also das Hillsborough thematisiert. Es ist so – ich werde das Gefühl nicht los, dass gewisse Leute so – egal ob ich Journalist bin oder Privatperson oder vielleicht auch Jurist sogar, aber die dir so Verstehen geben wollen, also Liverpooler, vielleicht Betroffene, Spieler, wie ich gerade sagte, die irgendwie betroffen sind. Weil im weitesten Sinne, die so sagen, weißt du, auf welches Glatteis, auf welches moralische, juristisch, politische, vielleicht sogar sportliche Glatteis du dich hier begebst. So war immer die Rückmeldung, obwohl es immer höflich ist. Ich mag englischen Slang, ich mag englische Umgangsformen und so weiter. Ich kann damit, glaube ich, auch halbwegs umgehen. Es war nicht so, im Übrigen noch mal mit den Protagonisten, mit den Überlebenden, mit denen ich meinen Film gemacht und dementsprechend gebaut habe. Aber trotzdem war das immer so ein bisschen so, ich sag mal, weißt du, wo wir sprechen?
Naja, aber das ist, glaube ich, da liegt halt auch ein Misstrauen den Medien, beziehungsweise eigentlich jedem, der sich damit befasst, zugrunde, weil die halt einfach so lange erlebt haben, dass egal, was sie gesagt haben, es wurden immer andere Dinge behauptet. Und deswegen trauen sie es, glaube ich, dann auch jemanden, der von noch weiter außen kommt, noch weniger zu, das alles zu erfassen. Und dieses Gefühl hatte ich auch – und das konnte man auch in manchen Interviews heraushören, die man dann eben bei anderen Medien finden konnte. Also man findet ja zu Hillsborough sehr viel Dokumentation, auch durch andere Medien. Und das konntest du immer wieder spüren, dieses latente Misstrauen den Journalistinnen und Journalisten gegenüber, die sich mit diesem Thema befassen. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen, weißt du eigentlich, auf welches Glatteis du dich begibst, aber auch so ein bisschen dieses nicht schon wieder jemand, der jetzt Misstrauze hält.
Ja, und da würde ich jetzt mal behaupten, die Sun mit The Truth, eine wahnsinnige Mauer eingerissen, die nie wieder wirklich aufgebaut wurde. Und es ist nicht so, dass ich da verständnislos vorstehe und denke, ey, lass uns doch mal eben reden. So meine ich das gar nicht, aber trotzdem auch so ein bisschen in so, wie soll ich sagen, Zwischentönen. Also niemand ist verpflichtet, mit mir zu reden, weder on noch off camera. Das ist mir alles klar. Aber so ein bisschen auch so, wie soll ich das sagen? Ich hätte fast gesagt, manchmal so eine latente Arroganz in manchen Momenten. Auch das ist zynisch, aber in manchen Momenten habe ich da verspürt so, Alter, wir sprechen über Hillsborough. Ja, klar, schlimm und alles, aber ich will nur reden.
Ja, und für die wirkt es aber, als würdest du den Dalai Lama für eine Home-Story anfragen.
Ja, genau. So ein bisschen. Ich glaube, es ist klar geworden, was wir sagen wollen, dass bei uns so ein bisschen das nicht unverständlich ist, aber wir ein bisschen dafür brauchten, was Raphael Honigstein auch sagt. Man muss sich erst mal begreifen, also sich einlesen und dann irgendwie versuchen zu begreifen, warum das so krass emotionalisiert ist. Nicht in Anführungszeichen nur wegen 96 Todesopfern, sondern fast noch mehr. Weiß ich nicht, schwierig zu zu zu werten oder zu kategorisieren, aber fast noch mehr wegen der Nachgeschichte. Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte mit Mein Sohn ist zwei, wenn nicht gar dreimal gestorben.
Ja, das stimmt. Und deswegen fühlt sich auch über Hillsborough zu sprechen wie so eine große Last an. Also ich bin in diese Aufnahme nicht locker leicht reingegangen, sondern während der ganzen Zeit, in der ich versucht habe – ich habe hier wieder mal ein riesiges Sendungsdokument mir angelegt mit viel zu vielen Informationen – das war so ein Druck, alles akkurat abzubilden, die Daten richtig zu haben, die Namen zu haben, weil ich so das Gefühl hatte, ich will ja generell keine Fehler machen. Aber es fühlt sich dann in so einem Fall, in dem so viele Unwahrheiten verbreitet wurden, noch mal wichtiger an, dabei zu bleiben. Ich bin froh, dass wir die Sendung machen, aber deswegen fühlt sich da, da ist auch ein gewisser Druck allein wegen der Sache da, weil Hillsborough einfach Hillsborough ist.
Genau, es ist ein massives Spannungsverhältnis, weil man auch nie als Neutrale, als Journalist oder als Beobachtender, unbeteiligter einerseits, aber sich Einlesender, in der Retrospective, kuckender Mensch, man versucht sich trotzdem, auch das ist nur menschlich, nicht zu positionieren, aber sich so ein Bild zu machen, schlichtweg. Und das ist ein Spannungsverhältnis, das ist schwierig und das werde ich auch nicht los, deshalb schlafe ich nicht schlecht nachts, weiß Gott nicht, und das ist jetzt auch echt eine krasse Erhebung dessen. Aber ich komme da auch nicht weiter in diesen Gedanken, so viel muss ich sagen. Und ich kann nur dazu sagen, und deshalb finde ich schon, ja mag auch pathetisch klingen, aber irgendwie gut, dass ich diesen Film machen durfte und konnte und auch so einer, wie ich ihn eigentlich immer machen wollte, weil es ist wirklich so, ich erinnere mich immer noch, ich meine, gut, ich war auch elf Jahre, da kann ich mich auch in meinen Tränen erinnern. Also ich bin Jahrgang 78 und ich weiß noch genau, wie ich vor der Sportschau saß und mit meinem Vater das gesehen habe. Und es ist eigentlich ein normaler Spielbericht. Ich denke, ja gut, die kicken jetzt, da spielt irgendwie Liverpool gegen Schießmichtod, Nottingham Forest halt und so. Und ich weiß noch genau, wie wir vor dem Fernseher saßen, ohne die Reaktion noch genau zu kennen. Aber so für mich war Hillsborough immer, oder Sheffield, ich weiß, es gab auch schon nachher schlechte Witze immer über Sheffield, also immer so ein bisschen, ja, aber es war Sheffield, die ja 96 ein paar zerquetschte. Ja, aber so pubertierende Scheißjugend bezahlt gab es damals. Also Sheffield und Hillsborough waren in meiner Jugend, also 1989, oder Kindheit nahezu, immer ein Begriff und deshalb habe ich auch eine Liebe zu Nordengland und zu Liverpool und Manchester und da oben, ich will nicht zu weit ausführen, aber ich fand das irre, ich würde fast sagen lehrreich, da so einen Einblick zu bekommen, ohne dass ich da für mich zu so einem abschließenden Urteil schon mal gar nicht, aber ja, und so haben auch meine Protagonisten gesprochen, die sagen auch, tja, du findest da keinen Seelenfrieden, du nimmst da, das wird ewig und ewig weitergehen, das ist schlichtweg wie bei Love Parade, also jetzt sehr weit gespannter Bogen, aber bei Love Parade ist das Nicht-Urteil oder Halb-Urteil auch zu unzufrieden stellen.
Ja, und die Rolle der Medien ist aber auch dahingehend interessant, ich bin da reingegangen und man wusste ja das über die Sun und wusste ja auch vom Boykott und dann sind ja auch die Medien die Bösen, aber wenn man sich dann näher mit Hillsborough auseinandersetzt und dann auch die Frage stellt, warum kam das denn dann zum Beispiel 1997, 1998 nochmal auf, das hatte ja nicht nur mit einem Regierungswechsel in den UK zu tun und warum kam es dann 2009 nochmal auf, dann kommst du jedes Mal auf Dokumentation zurück, also es gab eben 1996, am 5. Dezember wurde dir dann ausgestrahlt eine Dokumentation von einem Liverpooler Filmemacher, Hillsborough hieß die, die war wesentlich dafür verantwortlich, dass dieses Thema bis dahin juristisch eigentlich abgeschlossen war. Es gab diesen gerichtsmedizinischen Prozess, es gab die Revision, da wurde das bestätigt. Sie haben es dann noch privat strafrechtlich probiert, sind da aber gescheitert, auch an Kosten. Also im Grunde war das gerade so in einer Phase, in der die Angehörigen auch nicht weiter kamen, in ihrem Bestreben, da für Klarheit zu sorgen. Da gab es diese Dokumentation und dann hat das Konkurrenzblatt, der Sun, der Mirror, der ja auch wusste, die Sun muss bei diesem Thema die Füße stillhalten, die haben dann ja fast schon eine Kampagne, würde ich sagen, gefahren rund um diese Dokumentation. Die haben schon Tage vorher angefangen zu erzählen, das wäre die wichtigste Dokumentation, die jemals produziert worden wäre. Das hättest du dir jetzt für deine sicherlich auch gewünscht und hat dann die Leserinnen und Leser dazu aufgerufen, bei den Abgeordneten anzurufen, hat Fragen formuliert und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass tatsächlich dann im Haus der Abgeordneten diese zweite Untersuchung angestoßen wurde. Und auch 2009 war es so, das ist ja dann der 20-jährige Tagestag der Jahrestag der Katastrophe. Auch da war es so, dass die Medienberichterstattung einen Teil dazu beigetragen hat, warum dieses Thema wieder wichtig wurde. Es hat dann zu Online-Petitionen geführt. Das war die erste Debatte im Haus der Abgeordneten, die damals auf Grundlage einer Online-Petition angestoßen wurde. Das war dann 2011. Der Guardian schmückt sich damit, allerdings auch auf seiner eigenen Seite, dass auch er damals so viel nochmal über die bestehende Trauer der Angehörigen berichtet hätte, dass es eben nochmal auf das Radar der Öffentlichkeit kam. Also diese Rolle der Medien gibt es eben auch. Es gibt eben nicht nur die Sun, die sich dann auch später noch versucht hat zu entschuldigen – oder sie haben sich entschuldigt, die Entschuldigung wurde aber nicht angenommen – sondern es gibt eben auch andere Medien, die eben auch eine andere Rolle in diesem Umgang mit der Tragödie spielen.
Ja, letztendlich viel zu viele, wie soll ich sagen, ich hätte ganz blöd gesagt, viel zu viele Player in dieser ganzen Gemengelage. Also einerseits gibt es die verschiedenen Ebenen, wie wir schon erörtert haben – moralisch, politisch, juristisch, emotional ist ein bisschen das Gleiche wie moralisch – und dann aber auch diese Strömung auch medial. Dann sportlich sei jetzt mal ganz blöd, United, Liverpool und Blader wird sich auch nichts gegönnt. Dann Liverpool-London, also jetzt auch wieder politisch gesehen, die Liverpooler sagen ja auch, die Leute in dieser London-Bubble, die wollen mit uns nichts zu tun haben. Es ist, und das auch wieder, was ja das Ausgangspunkt ist, so doof immer, aber so, es ist so viel, so viele Strömungen sind da drin, das kriegst du nicht gefasst.
Okay, um das, um jetzt mal das Faktische noch kurz abzurunden, erzähle ich noch einmal ganz kurz, was dann eben 2012 rauskam. Also von 2009 bis 2012 hat das Hillsborough Independent Panel unter Leitung des ehemaligen Bischofs von Liverpool, James Jones, eben dann noch mal alle Unterlagen untersucht. Und das war eben auch wichtig. Also es wurde eben nicht auf Grundlage dieser gerichtsmedizinischen Untersuchung vorgegangen, sondern es wurden noch mal alle Unterlagen herausgezogen und es kam dann eben ein Ergebnis heraus und gleichzeitig eine Webseite, auf der man mehr als 450.000 Seiten an gesammeltem Material online gestellt hat. Insgesamt waren es 800.000 Seiten, die man durchgearbeitet hat. Und folgende Dinge kamen dabei heraus. Zum einen, die Liverpool-Fans sind unschuldig am Tod der 96. Grund war ein Fehlverhalten der Polizei und fehlende Maßnahmen zur Sicherheit. Habe ich vorhin schon erwähnt, bis zu 41 der 96 Opfer hätten durch bessere medizinische Erstversorgung gerettet werden können und 164 Zeugenaussagen wurden verändert. 116 davon hatten negative Aussagen über die South Yorkshire Police in sich, die dafür zuständig war. Und die Polizei hat diese Passagen entfernt. Das alles konnte belegt werden und das führte dann auch zu der Entschuldigung von David Cameron, die wir auch im Intro gehört haben, wo er eben den beteiligten Familien, die Double Injustice, die ihnen widerfahren ist, sich dafür entschuldigt hat, dass sie...
Genau, diese Dimension lässt sich natürlich nicht auf andere Länder oder auch nicht auf Deutschland Münzen, aber allein mal diese Vorstellung – Gott sei Dank hat es das nie gegeben, aber dass ein Bundeskanzler, Bundeskanzlerin sich bei einem Club, bei einer Fanschar entschuldigt. Wie gesagt, das ist hier alles nicht passiert, aber nur mal um so klarzumachen. Angela Merkel stellt sich in einer Bundespressekonferenz dahin und sagt, ich entschuldige mich bei den Fans von Hertha BSC. Nur so jetzt, weil es ist natürlich komplett gesponnen. Das ist schon einfach nur, um dimensional zu denken wieder. Das ist schon eine Tragweite.
Das zeigt die Gravitas. Und das zeigt aber, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen, dass die Politik eben auch eine Rolle spielt. Das wird immer nur so am Rande gestreift und da ist es da auch noch am schwierigsten nachzuweisen, wer da was getan hat. Ich glaube, dass eben diese Untersuchungen, in denen eben vornehmlich Richter, Gerichtsmediziner oder eben auch Politiker involviert waren, dass die vorher zu anderen Ergebnissen kamen, das wirft ja auch ein schlechtes Licht auf alle beteiligten politischen Partner, hätte ich jetzt gesagt, Parteien, alle, die an diesen Vorgängen Anteil hatten. Und ich glaube, das schwingt auch noch in dieser Gravitas mit und auch in dieser Demut, in der sich dann Cameron da vor den Opfern verbeugt hat und ja auch Theresa May, die damals Innenministerin war und dafür zuständig war, eben diese Untersuchung anzuleiten und die dann eben entschieden hat direkt nach herauskommen, diese Reports nach der Entschuldigung von David Cameron, hat sie angeordnet, dass alle Untersuchungen jetzt auch nochmal juristisch aufgeräut werden sollen. Daher kommt das auch nicht. Ich glaube, das hängt auch damit zusammen, was nicht nur in der Aufarbeitung nach Hillsborough passiert ist, sondern auch welche Folgen das hatte. Das haben wir jetzt vorhin immer nur so angedeutet unter anderem sind ja eben dann auf Grundlage des Taylor-Reports, ausgelöst durch Hillsborough, die Stehplätze aus den Stadien verschwunden, erst aus ganz Großbritannien und dann hat auch FIFA und UEFA haben dann auch sehr schnell Sitzplatzstadien gefordert für ihre Wettbewerbe. Also das alles ist auf Hillsborough zurückzuführen.
Die Leute, mit denen ich da zu tun hatte, also einer hat diesen hochtrabenden Satz benutzt und mir geht das auf einen Standen zu weit. Unter diesem Motto fand auch letztendlich eine Lesung am Millantor statt für diesen Buch The Hillsborough Voices. Das ist von Kevin Samson ein Buch, welches ich sehr empfehlen kann, wo es eben hauptsächlich die Überlebenden geht, also die Stimmen von Hillsborough, wenn man so will. Den habe ich da kennengelernt und das war vor so einigen Wochen am Millantor oder Monaten schon, da waren die wie Hamann, Marco Bode, Ewald Lien, die haben aus diesem Buch gelesen, noch mal sehr empfehlenswert. Aber ich meine, dieser Abend, also diese Lesung wurde so betitelt, der Tag, an dem der Fußball starb. Und das hat auch einer meiner Protagonisten gesagt, that was the day that football really died in England. Und er behauptet, ich finde, das ist eine vage These oder eine steile, dass Hillsborough dazu geführt hat, was die Premier League heute ist. Das ist natürlich ein sehr weiter Bogen. Aber Fetcher hat damit mit Hillsborough gewisse Kräfte oder auch Strömungen oder auch Dinge umsetzen können, die die Premier League oder die FA dazu gemacht haben, was sie heute ist. Ob man das jetzt in Sky und Beaty Sports und all dem Scheiß wirklich gleichsetzen kann. Aber ich sag mal, ich kann damit im Ansatz was mit anfangen. Weil 1989 war Fußball in England, wie du vorhin sagst, ist völlig richtig, käfig, rau, saufen, also auch Alkohol im Stadion schlichtweg auch noch erlaubt. Nochmal, ob man das gut oder schlecht findet, sei dahingestellt. Aber für gewisse, ich sag mal, Althauer aus Liverpool, so sag ich es jetzt einfach mal, war das der Tag, an dem der Fußball für sie begann, nicht mehr der zu sein, der er für sie mal war. Für mich ist das ein bisschen weit gefasst, ohne dass ich seit Jahren auf der Insel lebe oder so. Aber es gibt Stimmen, die das behaupten.
Ja, ich glaube, für Teile der Fans stimmt das sogar. Also was ja dann passiert ist, durch die Sitzplätze, also die Vereine haben das dann eigentlich sogar ganz gerne gemacht, diesen Taylor Report umgesetzt, der auch vorgesehen hatte, das sollte man nicht unterschlagen, dass auch die Käfighaltung der Fans abgeschafft wurde. Also es gab dann auch keine Pants mehr auf den Tribünen. Aber das hat eben dazu geführt, zum einen hat es gekostet, die Kosten wurden weitergegeben an die Fans und dann hattest du aber zwar weniger Plätze in deinem Stadion, aber die konntest du zu viel höheren Ticketpreisen verkaufen. Und da gab es dann schon Untersuchungen, dass das der erste Moment war, in dem sich die Tickets in eine solche finanzielle Region entwickelt haben, nach der Umsetzung dieses Taylor Reports, eben dem Umbau zu Sitzplatzstadien, dass es eben einen Teil der Fans gab, der es sich nicht mehr leisten konnte, ins Stadion zu gehen. Und dadurch hat sich dann die Fan-Kultur im Stadion und dann auch die Fan-Kultur in den Pubs – darin konnte man sich es dann nämlich noch halbwegs leisten – hat sich verändert. Also aus diesem Blickwinkel betrachtet ist für einige vielleicht wirklich der Fußball an diesem Tag gestorben, weil ihnen wurde dann im Folge der Ereignisse der Zugang in den Stadion verwehrt, weil er einfach zu teuer wurde.
Genau. Und wenn man so will, wenn man das jetzt weiter spinnt und aus deren Sicht das betrachtet, also jetzt mal aus so einer – ich will jetzt bewusst das Wort Hooligans mal ausklammern – aber so aus so rauer Casual-Sicht von damals, die ja an Hillsborough nicht schuld waren, wurde eigentlich was genutzt, an dem sie – ich hätte fast gesagt ausnahmsweise nicht schuld waren, klingt jetzt auch wieder finster – aber wurde was genutzt, welches Dinge auf dem Weg geschoben haben, welche sie gar nicht wollten. Also, dass man da – jetzt 30 Jahre später, es ist sehr weit gefasst, erneut – aber dass man da denkt, fuck, wir waren da gar nicht dran schuld. Aber ihr habt es instrumentalisiert, um es ganz verkürzt darzustellen, damit kann ich eine Menge anfangen. Das muss ich auch irgendwie, oder ja, doch, damit kann ich was anfangen, ja.
Und so hat sich eben der Fußball in ganz England verändert. Für Liverpool, also den Club, FC Liverpool, hat es natürlich auch große Folgen. Neben dem, dass es ein Thema ist, das eben bis heute wichtig ist, kommen auch die beiden Fackeln im Wappen kommen. In Gedenken an die Opfer von Hillsborough. Der Schriftzug You'll Never Walk Alone wurde dann auch erst ergänzt ins Wappen. Also das sind Folgen von Hillsborough, die wir heute noch sehen. Also dieser ganze, dieses Weitertragen des Gedenkens an Hillsborough, als hätte ich fast auch Mythos gesagt, aber das ist dann das falsche Wort. Und ich habe das Gefühl, und da wird mich jetzt deine Meinung zu sehr interessieren, weil du im Gegensatz zu mir schon vor Ort warst, dass sich auch das Verhältnis zu Everton dadurch nochmal verändert hat. Man spricht ja jetzt vom Friendly Derby, das hatte früher auch viel damit zu tun, dass eben viele Familien sowohl blaue als auch rote Fans haben. Aber im Nachgang zu Hillsborough waren ja die Everton-Fans vielleicht diejenigen noch im ganzen Land, die am dichtesten an der Seite der Liverpool-Fans standen.
Die sind natürlich nicht weit voneinander entfernt. Das erste Liga-Spiel danach, wenn ich richtig liege, war ja gegen Everton. War das so? Moment, das Wiederholungsspiel gegen Nottingham Forest war im Old Trafford, Manchester. Genau, das war da und da hat mir einer der Überlebenden geschildert, da ist er hin, obwohl er noch komplett traumatisiert von Hillsborough war. Und er ist auf einen Polizisten losgegangen und hat ihn so am Schlawittchen gepackt und hat ihn angebrüllt, weil er überhaupt nicht mit dieser Stadionsituation klar kam. Also bis hin dazu, dass er damals klar psychologische Beratung gebraucht hätte, aber Männer in England 1989 machten das nicht und so weiter. Das fand ich ganz interessanter an Respekt. Zurück zu Everton Liverpool. Ich meine, das war das erste Liga-Spiel, da sind dann sehr symbolträchtig, aber wie ich es finde, eine sehr schöne Geste. Ich meine, zwei Kinder, ein Kind eben in blau und ein in rot, Hand in Hand auf den Platz gelaufen. Ich meine, das war das erste Liga-Spiel, dann der Friendly Derby. Ja, ja, schon irgendwie, aber es schwächt ab. Es ist auch eben 30 Jahre her. Everton ist schlichtweg auch betroffen gewesen. Also Familien oder Fans von Everton kannten. Da sind wir wieder bei der Kleinstadt Liverpool, hätte ich fast gesagt, waren auch betroffen. In irgendeiner Form kennt immer jemanden, irgendwen, der in Hillsborough umkam, da war, verletzt wurde, Gott weiß was. So und trotzdem meine Wahrnehmung der letzten Wochen und Monate ist, so friendly ist das alles auch gar nicht mehr. Also man mag sich auch nicht zwingen. Man steht, glaube ich, was das Thema Hillsborough angeht, auch im derzeitigen Prozess. Da habe ich ein paar Everton-Leuten, auch vom Verein gesprochen, beieinander, zueinander. Aber rein sportlich ist das schon, da werden jetzt nicht die Messer gewetzt, aber friendly derby, wenn ich diesen Ausdruck immer benutzt habe, weil ich finde, das ist eigentlich eine schöne Geschichte. Ganz klar, also ist doch gar keine Frage. In der Stadt derby in Hamburg und St. Pauli haben wir vor Ort, da kannst du die Hubschrauber am Tag nicht im Himmel zählen und ein friendly derby ist ja irgendwie ganz schön, aber meine Gespräche haben mir gegeben, das ist so auch nicht mehr.
Und glaubst du nach deiner Erfahrung und deiner Erfahrung, die du jetzt machen konntest, dass Hillsborough auch noch mit diesem Underdog-Image zu tun hat, dem ja auch der Club FC Liverpool irgendwie immer wieder beispringt oder vermische ich da jetzt sportliches mit nicht sportlichem?
Also ich glaube nicht, dass der FC Liverpool ein großes Underdog-Problem hat, der Verein selber, es ist schwierig, den Verein von der Stadt abzukoppeln. Die Stadt hat ein Underdog-Problem, die Stadt – also sehr pauschal gesprochen, bitte nicht falsch interpretieren – aber mein Eindruck, meine Wahrnehmung ist, dass die Stadt nicht ein Underdog-Problem hat, aber sich in der Underdog, in der demütigen Rolle speziell gegenüber London, nicht ganz unwohl fühlt. So möchte ich es mal sagen. Aber daraus eben diese krasse Stärke, diese krasse, in sich gewachsene lokalpatriotische Stärke bezieht. Das ist mein Eindruck, den ich weder belegen noch irgendwas kann. Liverpool FC selber, sind sie immer noch Rekordmeister eigentlich?
Ne, United dürfte die abgelöst haben, glaube ich.
United dürfte die lange abgelöst haben. Okay, aber dann sind sie der Zweite, wie auch immer. Aber es ist ja ein Club mit wahnsinnigen Erfolgen und großer Historie, also historischen Erfolgen, mache ich damit. Ich glaube nicht, dass Liverpool FC ein Problem im Underdog da sein hat. Natürlich passt ein Trainer wie Jürgen Klopp dazu, der das bei Borussia Dortmund auch nicht ganz schlecht performt hat. Im Übrigen passt Klopp ja deshalb. Auch das habe ich unterschätzt, ohne dass mich das überrascht hat, dass der da gemocht wird. Aber der wird ja nicht gemocht. We are Club-Believers. Was sagen die über Justin Bieber? Justin-Bieber-Fans sind ja auch Believers oder Be-Biebers.
Beliebers, glaube ich.
Ja, eben so ein Quatsch. Und die heißen alle We are Club-Believers, sagen sie. Die folgen den Blindlings, was irgendwie ist ja okay so. Aber Club ist auch rein von der – ich habe da mit einem Journalisten drüber gesprochen – in Liverpool, der ist auch nicht unpassend für diese ganze und was wir die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen sagen zu dieser ganzen, ja, uns geht es nicht, uns wird auch immer so ein bisschen unrecht getan. Auch zurecht ja auch. Auch zurecht haben wir gerade über 30 Jahre erörtert. Aber da passt ein Club auch nicht schlecht zu mit seiner ganzen Haltung. Ist ein guter Trainer, zweifelsohne. Also ich bin jetzt mal abgekoppelt vom Sportling, auch von seiner Mentalität. Er hat auch sehr schnell, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, dass die Sun Boycott Klaviatur mitgespielt, was jetzt mal zynisch gesprochen auch nicht unklever ist. Also Club passt da schon hin. Ich muss auch trotzdem sagen, oder was heißt trotzdem, dass ich irgendwie auch, weiß ich, dazu war ich jetzt auch zu häufig da und habe auch einige Menschen dort irgendwie so schon irgendwie auch logischerweise liebgewonnen. Ich würde ihnen das dies Jahr auch echt krass wünschen. Das muss ich schon irgendwie sagen. Fan ab jeglicher. Ich war nie ein Liverpool-Fan, nie was anderes und weißt du, wie ich meine? So irgendwie.
Ja, klar. Ich meine, du hast es ja vorhin gesagt. Die letzte Meisterschaft war in der Saison 89, 90. Seitdem nichts mehr gewonnen. United, ich habe es noch mal schnell nachgeguckt übrigens, dann seit 2011 Rekordmeister. Die haben jetzt 20 Titel. Liverpool hat 18 Mal die Liga gewonnen. Und sie waren eben noch einmal nah dran mit dem Don't Let It Slip von Steve Jarrah, der dann, ich glaube, doch sogar im Spiel gegen Chelsea ausgerutscht ist bei diesem Querpass, dadurch dann dieses Spiel noch verloren geht und City dann Meister wird. Sie waren schon mal so nah dran und jetzt eben wieder, jetzt wäre es im Jahr des 30-jährigen Jahrestages der Hillsborough-Katastrophe, da würde schon sehr viel zusammenfallen und eben trotzdem noch die Aussage von allen Liverpool-Fans, die ich kenne, dass sie sagen, niemand würde es uns gönnen. Also ich hätte ja die These gehabt, außer City-Fans, United-Fans, Chelsea-Fans und Spurs. Hätten vielleicht alle gesagt, nee, das ist jetzt schon mal verdient, aber die behaupten felsenfest mir gegenüber immer, niemand in ganz England wird uns diesen Titel gönnen.
Und daraus ziehen sie stärker aus meiner Sicht. Also das ist auch relativ menschlich oder logisch. Ich habe viele gefragt, weil ich war beim Spiel Liverpool gegen Bayern, beim Hinspiel war ich im Anfield-Stadion und da habe ich mit Leuten da gesprochen und gefragt, was ist euch denn wichtiger? Champions League oder Meisterschaft? 110 Prozent Zustimmung, Meisterschaft. Wirklich, Meisterschaft. Es muss die Meisterschaft sein. Dieses Jahr muss es die Meisterschaft sein. Champions League, muss man ehrlich sagen, hatten sie immerhin 2005 war, glaube ich, Istanbul. Also ist nicht so weit her wie 1990 logischerweise, aber wie aus der Pistole geschossen.
Ja, das sagt Stevie G auch in der Doku, die es über ihn gibt, Make a Stream heißt die, ich glaube, die wurde von Amazon produziert, kann man deswegen wahrscheinlich da sehen. Da geht es eben um ihn und da wird natürlich auch diese Champions League Finale mit dem 3-3 nach 0-3 aufgearbeitet und dann eben dem Elfmeterschießen. Und der sagt aber auch, das war schon wichtig, weil wir haben dann auch den Titel da geholt und es ging halt auch in dieser ganzen Gemengelage, dass Michael Owen dann wechselt zu Real und so weiter. War das wichtig? Aber du merkst auch aus jeder Silbe bei ihm, der ja auch dadurch, dass das jüngste Opfer von Hillsborough ein Cousin von ihm war, eine sehr persönliche Verbindung zu dieser Tragödie hatte, dass er das auch so sieht, dass er sagt, die Meisterschaft ist das, was zählt. Das wurde da auch sehr deutlich in der Doku.
Ja, ja, das ist schon, finde ich auch interessant. Und im Übrigen, das ist jetzt auch wenig überraschend, aber daran will natürlich keiner denken. Aber alle sagen natürlich, wenn wir irgendwann mal keine Club-Believer mehr sind, dann muss natürlich Stevie G kommen, der bei den Rangers im Moment ist. Also das ist die logische Folge dann.
Wobei es ja nicht wahnsinnig erfolgreich für ihn läuft, aber das geht jetzt dann in einen tagesaktuellen Part drüber. Also am Sonntagabend um 23.35 Uhr im NDR und danach hoffentlich ja in der Mediathek?
Ja, habe ich heute klären können, in der Mediathek.
Video-Recorder? Wer hatte noch ein Video-Recorder? Also dann läuft deine Doku. Was hast du denn aus deiner Recherche gelernt? Wie lange ging dir jetzt eigentlich? Das hörte sich, du hast immer mal wieder schon so angedeutet, hört sich nach einem langwierigen Prozess an.
Ja, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Ach, na ja, wie es so ist. Irgendwie hast du so einen Jahrestag dann auf der Uhr und so ein bisschen, was ich vorhin meinte, das gehört jetzt nicht zu Recherche, aber ich wollte immer mal was, so lapidar das jetzt erstmal klingt, was über Hillsborough machen, aber dann fing ich so im letzten Herbst so an, die ersten Leute anzurufen, zu fragen und jetzt war ich tatsächlich relativ häufig in den letzten sechs, sieben Wochen drüben, um natürlich erstmal Leute kennenzulernen, weil das, wie wir jetzt häufig feststellen, sensibel war oder sensibel ist und dann irgendwann muss ja auch drehen und so weiter, aber so angefangen habe ich so im letzten Herbst, aber dann auch immer mit Unterbrechung, also jetzt nicht dauerhaft nur durchdrehen, dann durch, dran gesessen, aber die letzten fünf, sechs Wochen war es dann schon sehr streng daran, ja.
Und wie lange hättest du dir die Doku gemacht, wenn es so wäre wie hier im Podcast, dass man so lange wissen kann, wie man will? Also, sie dauert jetzt eine halbe Stunde.
Genau, sie dauert eine halbe Stunde.
Aber ich konnte schon eine Vorabversion sehen und mag sie euch sehr, sehr, sehr empfehlen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schaut ihr euch auf jeden Fall an, vor allem, weil es auch noch mal einen Bereich beleuchtet, den wir jetzt gar nicht so sehr behandelt haben, weil eben einfach die Geschichten der Überlebenden noch mal in den Mittelpunkt gerückt werden. Und das ist einfach – das reißt einen mit. Mich hat es sehr bewegt beim Gucken. Es ist ein sehr, sehr toller Film geworden. Glückwunsch dazu, Ole. Und danke, ein richtiger Glücksfall, auch für den Rasenfunk. Danke, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, hier bei uns mit darüber zu sprechen. Danke dir. Das war Ole Zeisler, et mods ole, auf Twitter mit Doppel-Z. Und hört natürlich den Doppelpass, den Doppel-Sechs-Podcast, meine Güte. So spät geht es dann dahin, den Doppel-Sechs-Podcast. Natürlich nicht den Doppel-Pass-Podcast. Doppel-Sechs-Podcast, sehr empfehlenswert. Da könnt ihr Ole dann noch häufiger lauschen. Und damit herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit hier im 32. Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Max Jacob-Ost. Ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter. Freue mich, über Feedback zu dieser Ausgabe. Und dann hören wir uns demnächst mal wieder in einem unserer Formate in der Schlusskonferenz, dem Tribünengespräch oder dem Kortzpass. Habt eine gute Zeit. Bis dahin, machts gut, ciao. Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.